hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021
my name is camila and i am the session
chair for this chat for this session i
would like uh to ask you please if you
feel comfortable in doing so to add your
pronouns to uh your name uh at zoom uh
please also just try to have in there
the name that you would like to be
calling throughout this session
if at any time when i'm reading out uh
your questions for example please
my apologies uh feel free to amuse my uh
to a mute and just correct me at any
time i would also like to remind uh
regarding our code of conduct
and that if any moment anything arises
just please feel free
to send me a message
i would like now to hand over to oidia
and she's going to be the moderator for
this session
um thanks camila for for giving us uh
this stage
this afternoon so we are going to start
now for with this workshop which is
called um
with this workshop sorry um
so
we are i'm going to share my screen
thanks for coming this afternoon or this
morning uh depending on where you are
located or even this night
to take for fosterity which are which is
the workshop and workshop i will be
running this afternoon uh in order to
talk about the challenges for the future
uh in topics uh like ai ethics and dei
so the gender for this for today is the
following
uh uh
so we are going to have several talks uh
starting with the bogo
and we will have an open discussion
after maurice
and for sure we will have two panels uh
regarding how to overcome imposter
syndrome and another one about the
future of work
so uh first of all i will uh present
myself
uh my name is idia and i'm based in
barcelona in spain i'm a data scientist
and at the moment i'm working as a
consultant in ai and civil society at um
at open society
and moa and my hobbies are traveling
reading sports and karaoke i have many
more but i think these ones are the ones
that i would highlight at the moment
so please feel free during this
afternoon or this evening or this
morning if you have any ideas regarding
these hobbies i will be super glad to
talk about it and also
if you have any questions just feel free
to add me and um and i will be glad to
answer them
so uh i don't think i have anything else
so maybe we can start the vogue if you
are if you are ready
yeah we are going to start with the
vocals um
talk about aisx and dei because they are
really
a leadership responsibility so te voges
a multicultural south african citizen
and german president she's a consulting
pro a professional with more than 10
years experience in corporate social and
enterprise and the state
she is currently occupying an executive
position at balvesio international
and she's a german strategy and
management consulting firm in nuremberg
in bavaria
her expertise
in and passion for topics around
compliance digital ethics as well as the
impact of increasing digitization
are on matters pertaining to diversity
inclusion and representation
so uh i will hand over the flow for you
to you devote
and
yeah feel free to share your screen i'm
going to stop
thank you so much for introducing and my
topic i get right into it
so
i'd like to go just over the points that
are going to be covered today six of
them i'll try to give give each one of
them enough attention especially for
points to ponder and reflect on
very briefly thank you for the
introduction
and what perhaps is not
mentioned so much is that i love to
learn and continuous development and
growth
and
also
i'm an advocate of a healthy and
sustained relationship between tech
advancement for good
ai and digital ethics diversity equity
inclusion and belonging i'd like to
include today as well as accountable
corporate leadership which is so
imperative nowadays and responsibility
by everybody
so i don't need
to talk much about the tech advancement
and how astounding they've been right
literally in the last five years alone
from tree planting drones predictive
analytics 3d printing
i'm sure you'll be able to inform me
more about that
myself
however we've also seen a lot um about
the dark side of tech advancement
something that i'd refer to as the bad
and the ugly and i'm sure you i hope you
have watched the documentary coded bias
right where the problematic especially
the ethics issue pertaining to facial
recognition technology
was pointed out on in different aspects
then of course there were the headlines
right and
big corporate giants like amazon
uh facebook um ibm were
in the news
so i'm an academic at heart and i like
to work with frameworks with definitions
and i'm going to start off with the
definition of ai ethics and the one that
spoke to me most is the one that was
presented by the european parliament
last year and namely that ai ethics is
concerned with the important question
of how human developers manufacturers
and operators
should behave
in order to minimize the ethical harms
that can arise from a.i and society
either arising from poor design
inappropriate application or misuse
i'd like to point out that one part of
this definition and i've highlighted it
there is that human being is central
it's capacity as i'm talking to the
developers to designers i'm talking to
corporate leadership and talk to users
consumers
everybody along the entire value team
and of ai products and services
secondly we need to consider the harm
and the negative impact on society that
requires to be minimized
all aspects of society
of course social
um
social
acceptability
of products and services i'm talking
about the environment as well i'm
talking about where these technologies
are sourced with the raw material a
source and society there again placing
the human being
um in the
center
and very important is also the
responsibility on us humans
along and across the entire life cycle
of ai products
and services
so
i'm a jurist
so frameworks guidelines law regulation
i'm here for it and i'll let you in
later on why it's so important to
consider and to really invest the time
and the effort to look
at the international ai ethics
frameworks and guidelines because there
are so
many of them which delights me
the first one is the european
commission's ethics guidelines for
trustworthy ai and this one i like to
refer to in some other talks as well
because it's aligned with the eu's gdpr
right the general and data protection
regulation which one of the strictest
data protection regulation in the world
currently
and these guidelines are very practical
and even have case studies
and to ensure not only compliance but
also
data and the digital and ai ethics the
oecd did the same thing so the institute
of business ethics even microsoft
you know
giving out guidelines for responsible
bots open ai and many others
so
yes i did say i'm a jurist i like laws
regulations but why follow frameworks
and guidelines
fact is
that no technology and algorithm is
socially or politically neutral
you probably ask yourself how do i
notice because i'm not a psychologist
this
i like this picture i think that
summarizes very succinctly
in modern times
individuals are said
to be influenced by 50 cognitive
different cognitive biases
that impact and affect different
decision makers decision making across
the board i'll just pick out two or
three of the most prevalent one
one is confirmation bias focusing on
information that only confirms the
existing
preconceptions sounds familiar right
especially when corporate leaders say
we did loads of simulations most of them
showed there's no problems
another one that also spoke to me and
that's so very common nowadays
is the status quo bias preferring the
current state of affairs rather than
change i'm sure you've all heard the
term if it ain't broke why fix it
uh
so
at lara to move on i wrote in my the
beginning of our presentation diversity
equity and inclusion
belonging is playing a much more
important role in all these discussions
right and in the concept around
diversity equity and inclusion
and also here i'd like to talk to
corporate leadership right when they
deal with these aspects to consider some
of these primary concepts and these
questions
firstly who is in the room
but make sure that there are different
opinions of background
social groups um
genders you know sexual orientations and
they so it's a plethora and a prism of
differentness that we could all
um get from to produce better products
and more acceptable products and
services
then of course equity asks who is trying
to get in the room but can't because of
existing barriers
and i took the liberty to include the
smaller picture at the bottom making the
distinction between equality and equity
because often the very tall person in
the equality
picture
on the left or my left does not
understand these additional measures
that companies society some even
governments introduce
um to assist the shortest person on the
far right
it's not to make the person on far right
taller or give them advancement of
unfair advantage but as you will see to
level the playing field for everybody
inclusion is also key and here the
question that's asked is
has everybody's ideas been heard
respected and understood
as a minority in any fashion at every
capacity you know what i'm talking about
and as business leaders and team is
important to also consider that all the
voices and opinions are indeed heard
belonging
for me is also very important
and that looks into whether people feel
valued and comfortable enough to bring
the
authentic self to work
um this can definitely be undermined for
people who are part of the majority
group right um where their authentic
self is put as the norm
and i was asked the other day um
if i'm really am
an executive at a consultant because of
my nappy hair
this is how i bring my authentic health
to work
um
what's very important in this whole
consideration of diversity equity
inclusion and belonging is that it has
to be an action
i've seen so many websites and companies
that use these as these issues as
marketing gimmicks right without the
actual commitment
for example immigrant diversity and on
my left
literally put in sort of goals
in certain
years to reach certain goals by a
certain year and also which enabling
initiatives to introduce
this makes me happy oh
i hope and this shows that they do mean
business in this aspect
and about doing group actually has
created key metrics to measure
diversity here i'm also a comfort that
they do put in the effort that's
necessary
i'd like to summarize um the diversity
equity inclusion and belonging
considerations as follows that diversity
is a fact
please don't go to your history books to
try to prove it because they don't have
everything
right or they didn't put everything the
real truth of history or the inclusive
truth of history
secondly equity is a choice
inclusion is an action
and belonging the outcome
now i'd like to address corporate
leadership
personally actually any person in a
position of leadership and who's joined
this
part of the conference
and
i like this quote by stephen alcove
which i posted here which says
accountability breeds responsibility
i mean how important is it for companies
to be very quick to respond in these
very rapidly changing times right
i'd like to start with the obvious
this very vast and rapid digital
transformation requires adaptation of
businesses and business models of course
the relocation of resources as well as
investment in workforce training and
future demands i'm sure there's nothing
new here
furthermore
i feel the following are imperative
first of all acknowledging their own
biases that we all have biases and
imperfections
actually being human really and that for
us to challenge
to show this humanness to others as well
and also
it is also time for especially the
bigger and older corporates to change
the management ideas and ideals you know
and to make things like trust
autonomy compassion consultation
collaboration the new order of the day
open mindset must be manifested
and here as they ask ask ask rather than
assume because as soon as we all assume
please think of that picture i posted
earlier on the brain and all the 50
different types of biases
that accompany us every day
the last point um
it's it's quite a no-brainer but i
struggle a lot with it today when i
interact with certain
um peer executives
that people want to go back to how
things work that will never happen
instead we are all must embrace the
discomfort of the new normal which may
never be
i'd like to give
leisure some souvenirs for the world
i think i've mentioned couple of times
that human beings are in the center
and especially in terms of
accountability
responsibility consideration and the
plight of human beings along the value
chain
of everything that we do and for us to
also think longer term
comprising ethics should be established
and should be part and should be
prioritized from the onset
um
no
entity wants to end up
in a paper as a scandal you know like
facebook ibm and others
many
human advices should be minimized
consciously um it is also great that so
many courses and assistance has
developed especially the last one and a
half to two years where we can really
inform ourselves to do things better and
to be better so that we can get better
also
and now i'm talking i think uh to the
programmers
and
you know data analysts that the
collection and processing of personal
data should
done
very limitedly there are also numerous
guidelines on that
ask facebook i mean they were
hit with a whopping fine of almost 900
000 us dollars not too long ago
also be vigilant on cyber security your
business
depends on it
last but not least i implore all of us
to live and lead with responsibility and
accountability
that's what we need more than ever and
is tested on a daily basis by all the
decisions that we make
i'd like to end my contribution and with
a quote for one of my biggest heroes
um the late maya angelou who said
do the best you can until you know
better
but then
when you know better
do better
i hope that this contribution we now
know better and that we now we will all
do better
thank you
thanks devongo for your amazing speech
it's been very spiritual
and i hope we have many questions
arising from i'm pretty sure about it
about your topic
so let's see if we have any questions
for you
for example there's alfred who asks if
um
doesn't having so many frameworks and
guidelines confuse matters
or one can spend an eternity
understanding and reconciling these
frameworks for example what do you think
that's a great question um and indeed
i've
the nice thing about these frameworks
they often cover
similar foundations things like
transparency you know things like
diversity and all these various so
even though they do have different focal
points
um their bases and their foundations are
all the same
and i've read also actually this morning
uh
another academic article in that regard
that there are certain
points that are like a golden thread
through them all
thank you for the question
yeah in the end i think it seems like
it's more about values
or the values that we have in ourselves
than
what the company can can can think of
right yeah but
true right
um i do
still encourage everybody to have a look
at frameworks because
what people often do with ethics is add
a moral
twist on it
and what makes me a bit nervous about
that is that morality is also subjective
um i don't need to go too far back
in history and not too far
away across the world you know it's
still immoral
to have certain kind of hair right it's
still immoral for certain people who
look different to be in a relationship
so i tend to be a bit more cautious
around morals and i'd rather refer to
more objective guidelines
yeah so we have another question this
time from geode bogar who says uh what
can we do to get rid of our own biases
oh so much uh interact with people who
are different from you and
one of the
benefits of always having been
in a minority even in south africa um
you know school i was involved is that
you always seem to look out for other
minorities and you end up getting to
know
all of my friends
look different from me have a different
background
right so look for people who are
different have conversations ask
questions reach out
reach out
yeah
and we have another from jennifer saying
that at a practical level what are one
or two ways that developers and data
professionals can work these concepts
into products and models other than
limiting personal info
info collection
i go back to frameworks
and the law i mean already
california already has a data protection
act which is one of the strictest in the
u.s if not the strictest
so you will always be guided by that
there is always a guideline and for
startups
and for founders
just check what the law says
and the nice thing about the internet is
that there's always somebody who
interprets and then has
translated the law
into practical steps
so literally when you even before you
design you have your idea of the product
you want to produce
please just
go to those guidelines secondly make
sure you're in your team nobody looks
like you nobody's from the same high
school
nobody
is the similar to you it's not always
easy it's
worth it though because it reflects the
world as it is
you're so many you're so different
yeah that's true maybe we should learn
from each other and um definitely and
and from there we can always learn
something else
absolutely yes
so thanks a lot tebogo if you have any
more questions and for her you can
[Music]
ask her directly in the message
through the chat on linkedin
please connect and also on linkedin if
you want to connect with her that would
be great
so
i think we should move now to the next
um session thanks to vogel
thank you
our next next speaker is marie rocker
jones
yeah so marie is the c that the co-c
office team
which is a software-as-a-service
solution that helps employees take
action on courses that they care about
in the dai space
steam helps companies move their
sustainability initiatives forward by
converting idealistic intentions into
measurable actions she's a social impact
startup founder with over 10 years of
experience in leading gender and racial
diversity strategies
as the founder of raising great men
she built a movement for parents
empowering them with resources to raise
culturally aware and socially conscious
children
she was the senior editor for the
goodman project
a multimedia cross-platform site that
asks
what does it mean to be a good man in
the 21st century
marie also has workforce and career
development experience creating
workforce re-entry programs for
underrepresented communities through
coalition building employment readiness
networking opportunities and community
outreach
marie was the lead for the charter for
compassion's compassion at new york city
and through her project compassion
convos facilitated cross-sectoral
dialogue to examine implicit biases and
their impact on our perception of
criminality economic disparities
educational underachievement
health disparities and other factors
that bring about
social stratification and separation
so marie i welcome you and
please um
the floor is yours
okay thanks good morning or good
afternoon good evening everyone i'm so
happy to be here
thank you for taking time out to be here
um i
would first like to just make sure
everybody's doing well so i just wanna
if you can just post
in the um
in the chat i'm just gonna put something
a little quick icebreaker if you could
just post that in the chat can everyone
see it can you give me a thumbs up if
you see it
yeah we can see it okay so if
love to
connect with others so if you could just
put in chat what you're good at what is
the goal that you are setting the index
finger is called a five finger ice
breaker what is frustrating you right
now what are you committed to and a
little known fact about you so i'd love
to read that um
as i am getting myself set up with my
presentation
yes thank you
so today we're going to talk about
creating
trusted spaces for inclusion
this can be
difficult for
companies because a lot of companies
think about diversity and focus so much
on
the numbers and metrics and
really who are we bringing in to
build a diverse diverse workforce
that
not enough thought is put into
creating places for inclusion and
belonging and what that does is that it
unfortunately when you hire for
diversity
it does and you're not really thinking
about um
being inclusive the person that's hired
can sometimes feel just mentally and
emotionally drained from
dealing with microaggressions dealing
with
um
just subtle
uh
or sometimes even overt
racism or sexism whatever it may be so
we really want to talk about
how do you create um
psychologically safe spaces for people
and i want to
what i'm going to do today is presented
from both views
so for companies how can you do it and
for yourself as an employee how can you
make sure that you're in a safe space
for yourself
so one thing i like to talk about is the
four ways to do that because i think
when you make it simple
and
it's something you remember it stays
with you and it's not a lot of details
so
number one i say is be prepared
so
as an employee
one of the things you have to think
about is identifying what are your
values
and what's important to you and how do
you
stick to that and maintain that
in the workplace to keep yourself
mentally and emotionally safe
so knowing what your values are helps
you to when something's coming at you
know that how is this going to impact
what's important to me
and if it is impacting it in a way that
is detrimental to your health or
well-being or safety then you have to
make the decision is this the right
place for me so it's always being
prepared for that
the other thing i'd like to say is
understand your worth know
what you are worth
i think we spend so many time especially
in tech you build a lot of times
thinking about your technical experience
getting that job proving yourself but
always know what your worth is what is
the value you're bringing to that
company
know that and be able to articulate it
to yourself
and to others but if you don't know it
it's going to be hard for you to really
define that when you are coming up
against
someone maybe questioning
something you've done at work
if you know your worth you're able to
speak to
any error that you've made because we're
human you can make a mistake but it
doesn't take away your worth
and most importantly when you're
preparing
for making sure you're in a
psychologically safe space at work
identify people that can be trusted and
that could be difficult sometimes
because
our personal and professional lives
sometimes they overlap right and so
people you work with may become your
friends
but you have to really be mindful of
who's a real ally who will advocate for
you if you're in a meeting
or you're presenting
and someone says something to you who's
going to be the person that advocates
for you doesn't mean that they um speak
for you
or speak on your behalf but it means
they address anything
that may
be presented that negatively impacts you
and so for employers on the other side i
say
be open-minded about a new approach
meaning
be open-minded to thinking how can i
ensure that
everyone if you're on a team everyone on
my team
is heard
everyone on my team feels like they can
contribute in a meaningful way
so be open-minded be creative about how
do we approach this idea of creating
trusted and safe spaces
the other thing i say is engage all
employees when it comes to talk about
talking about company culture
your employees are your company culture
you don't have a company culture without
your employees without your team
they are who makes it so help let them
be the ones that define what that
culture is as a company can still have a
mission to still have values but your
culture
is not something that you can
just dictate it has to be something that
employees
are able to contribute to and tell you
what that culture is
also encourage an environment where
great ideas come from all levels of your
organization
there are you know you never know where
like a great idea is going to come from
so if you're not creating a space where
you know we talk a lot about having a
seat at the table which is kind of like
um
an analogy of like being able to
be there be present and and have a voice
but you cannot just give your employees
a seat at the table you have to allow
them to speak up too
so making sure that the environment
where ideas are welcome
and feedback is welcome
so that's one of the first things is the
preparation
the second i say is be authentic
and this is really key for both sides
because
as people of color particularly
um
we tend to code switch
meaning that
we don't bring our full selves we bring
the professional or corporate side we
think that is more accepting
and that other people are more
comfortable with
and what that does is that that lack of
authenticity can really contribute to
you feeling exhausted
mentally exhausted i've been in
workplaces where i've had to code switch
and at the end of the day when i get
home
i am mentally and physically exhausted
because what i've done is put on a mask
and
pretended well not pretended but i've
shown a different side of myself as
opposed to the real side because i feel
like some things may be misinterpreted
some things may be misconstrued but
if i had just been my authentic self and
understood going back to preparation
knowing my worth i wouldn't be
so quick to put that mask on
know your triggers
this is really
um
important
what triggers you
and if you know that you have to protect
yourself from
being in situations that can be
triggering can you always do it no but
one of the things you can do is
when you hear something or something is
said to you or colleague
stop and say am i triggered by this and
why
really explore that and if it means
taking a moment
to like if you're in a meeting and you
need to turn off your camera for a
moment
taking a pause because in that pause is
when you're gonna really be able to
you know bring it down
there is a part of our brain called the
amygdala and that's really the center
that controls our emotions
and what it does is sometimes our
amygdala
makes us just react right or respond in
a way so really think about when you're
triggered what is a way that you can
pull back for a moment
think about what is triggering you and
think about how you are going to respond
to that trigger but don't be so quick to
respond to it because in that moment
what you say
is going to be what people focus on
they're not going to focus on what was
said that triggered you it's how you
responded to it
and be honest with yourself what are
your needs you know what do you need and
want
be honest with your supervisors your
team members this is what i need and
want to be to feel that this is
inclusive
and there's nothing wrong in being
honest with yourself and others
um it's also it's always in the delivery
it's not always what we say it's how we
say it and being honest
um
doesn't mean that you have to
worry about how the other person
receives it
you have to think about how does it help
you to feel more psychologically safe
and also find the balance between
privacy and um collaboration and what i
mean by that is
what is it that you want to share and
what is it that you want to collaborate
with team members
as i said before they can overlap our
personal professional lives so really be
mindful of what you
feel
where you feel you can be transparent
and vulnerable
for employers i say build trust and
credibility by being authentic don't
just say don't just put up a black box
don't just
um
tweet
certain things because it looks good for
your brand
because internally employees
know that you're not being authentic and
what that does is now
it makes them not trust you so be
authentic
and be
you know you build trust by emphasizing
the process what's the process that
we're going to be inclusive what's the
process that we're going to create
in um
psychologically safe spaces for people
that work for us
be transparent and as mentioned before
give your employees a voice it doesn't
mean that um
people
have to be disrespectful or talk over it
just means that they have a voice once
you have a voice you feel safe enough to
call out something or mention something
so make sure that people don't feel like
they're being silenced especially when
things happen in the world that um are
traumatic
and happen to particular groups of
people be mindful of that and make sure
that i'm creating a space for people for
that
be accountable
employees
what i want to say is
take on anything you feel confident you
can handle and what that means is if
something
someone says something something happens
think about are you do you feel
confident enough to handle this or do
you need an advocate do you need someone
to be an ally for you
um know when to draw those boundaries
too
what are the boundaries that you don't
want people to cross or
overstep
don't let your ego get in the way and
what that means is don't let pride get
in your way of
accountability
especially if
on your end you feel that
something has been done and
you don't know how to address it
so don't let your ego get in your way of
really being able to express and be
yourself and know what you're able to
handle
because it goes back to
take on anything that you're confident
to handle know what you're able to
handle if it's something that's really
triggering and again
you feel that you need some time be
honest about that tell your supervisor i
need some time off i need some
what was said and this is why put it in
context for them
as an employer
um own up to your mistakes if you
put out something in public or even in
private internally own up to
you know what we made a mistake we
apologize to employees
and really think about how can you
rectify that don't just own the mistake
but rectify it be responsive to
employees issues if somebody is bringing
up to you someone just shared with me
about how she's working with someone and
daily she dealt with microaggressions as
a black woman
and her immediate supervisor who was a
white woman saw that and told her
i'm sorry you're dealing with that and
believed her it's really important
don't make people feel like they're
imagining what's happening more than
likely michael
aggressions are so subtle sometimes we
miss it
so don't just think somebody's saying
something because they're being overly
sensitive or don't make excuses that
this isn't how this person meant it
because you don't know how they meant it
so just listen
ask employees for feedback
ask them how are we doing what can we do
better
do you feel safe here and it could be
anonymous surveys but ask
and back up what you say with action if
you're gonna do something then do it
there are so many employee employers
that committed to dei and i think the
commitment was i don't want to give
wrong numbers but it wasn't billions and
what was actually done the action was in
the millions so a lot of companies did
not even fulfill those commitments so if
you're going to do something back it up
with the action don't just
use empty words
um
and i'm sorry with the numbering be
proactive is my last one
turn your frustrations into few
if you're frustrated about something let
it fuel you so that you can now feel
like again am i do i feel like i can
handle this turn that around so that you
feel empowered and document everything
documentation is the key for you to
feeling psychologically safer document
what's happening but the time the date
place who what
because that's the way you're going to
be able to now speak about it
confidently and also not let your ego
get in the way
and choose your battles on what you
think you'll gain or what you'll lose
um and i know i have five minutes and i
want to take time for questions choose
your battles if it's not worth it
then if it's not really
worth it and it's not affecting you in a
way that um
again it's triggering or you feel that
someone even if it's not you someone
else has been insulted think about what
are the where should you
really address it
and take care of your own psychological
needs if that means if you have
unlimited days
take those dates
don't just let them accumulate they're
there for a reason take those days and
take care of yourself for employers
communicate what you're doing to build
this inclusiveness
um
give your employees the opportunity to
be themselves
you know there's a lot of um
uh
black women and hair
and you know wearing braids so let
employees be themselves in a way that
those are not being disrespectful and
it's not anything where you're
appropriating another culture let them
be themselves encourage an open feedback
culture again as i said like let that be
what your company culture is about we
appreciate feedback
and actively listen to what is said and
not being said a lot of times a lot of
things can be learned in silence
and be inclusive of different ways of
working
including
work home offices because everyone it
has a different comfort level so some
people may have their camera off don't
oblige or make people feel they have to
have their camera on if someone doesn't
feel safe
then let them know it's okay
and um
you know i'm happy to share this
presentation i'm happy to answer any
questions i know we only have three
minutes but if anyone has any questions
please let me know and always happy to
connect with others on on linkedin to
um help you build your network
i'm going to turn it back to you
thanks marie for this amazing
presentation um i think it's super
useful to have
always tips for employees but also for
employers
which is sometimes it's when we have
this kind of topics or issues discussing
we are always focusing on one side or
the other one and never together so it's
it's a really good point to have them
all together in one in one separate
topic in one topic like this yeah
you're welcome and i know it's kind of a
difficult talk topic sometimes so
um
if you you know want to dm me or ask a
question
not in public i'm open to that so just
feel free and i will put my
uh linkedin
yeah just let me check if we have
questions for you i think we have
[Music]
um this is a comment i don't see any
questions
yeah i have one here just going to check
yeah for example geot is saying um how
do we differentiate between our own
perception of our abilities mental
abilities and soft skills and the
feedback perception that the team has
about my capabilities
that's a great question i think that's
where you document when you're
documenting everything that's when you
can now talk about
um
and ask questions if someone says we
don't feel that you know black women are
always being told smile more or
something like that um or when someone
says calm down
just people who are not even excited
but
ask questions if something is said ask
um what um
can you elaborate or can you give me an
example
ask those questions because then that
helps you to better know is there
something i need to work on or is there
a cultural difference in how i
communicate and my employer or my
supervisor so feel free to say can you
please elaborate can you please um give
me more um information and then have
your own
little like i said
documents to say well in that situation
here's how i handle this shows that
you're prepared and it shows that again
you know your worth and you can speak to
it
yeah and also jody was um
having an experience
that kept her thinking about this bad
experience for two days
um how in this case can we keep cool
if we are
thinking and overthinking about this bad
experience
any tip yeah tips if you need to speak
to someone if you have a mentor or if
you have a support network get back to
what i said about a trusted person if
that person is it could be inside or
outside speak to that person and give
them
the explain the background of everything
so that you have an understanding of
someone who's just objective right so
that doesn't have any stake in anything
and can honestly say to you okay i
understand why you feel this way and can
help you to stay calm as i mentioned
about the amygdala
one of the things you can do
that i do is like either
deep
you know breathe deeply or using your
hands if you're in a meeting if you
press your hands together it kind of
helps you to
stay calm but if you need the two days
then take those two days and if you need
to see like a therapist or someone a
career coach then do that do what you
need
that's going to help you because
everyone's going to have a different way
of coping with it so what is the coping
mechanism that you can put in place for
when that happens for you and who do you
have that can help you know support you
in that in that time
yeah
uh we have another question regarding
cultural appropriation
uh they say thanks for inspiring for
this inspiring presentation we are in a
such globalized world
how can i know more clearly about what
is cultural appropriation and what is
not
great question so
cultural appropriation so for example if
i were today to
um i could admire and appreciate
japanese culture
but if i
um and i you know it's interesting i was
in a a japanese
like fashion show it was and i was
dressed in a kimono but that was part of
the the exhibit or whatever it is but if
i just came today
and just wore a kimono
and had you know and just
really was trying to
speak in a way that really embraces
japanese culture
am i
showing appreciation or am i trying too
hard to take on a culture that's not
mine so the difference is
is that the admiration or appreciation
for another culture
can be spoken or shown in a way that
doesn't mean that i am trying to
in
that i'm trying to embody this you know
so there's something called black
fishing that a lot of people are talking
about on instagram where you have white
women that darken their skin so that
they can look a little bit more
ethnically ambiguous that's something
that would be called considered cultural
appropriation because you're trying to
look like and you're trying to
um
exhibit the characteristics of a
different culture
if somebody is wearing halloween that
celebrated here in the u.s
costumes sometimes you know some peop
someone's wearing
um
a headdress
you know that's
really and if you think it's a costume
it's not it's someone's culture so think
of it that way if you're putting on
something
that's not
really something that somebody can give
you a gift that's very different but
you're wearing it and every day you're
kind of trying to be
like this culture without even
really showing how you appreciate it
through
supporting the arts supporting um some
of the things they do so it's a fine
line but you feel it in your gut when
it's wrong
yeah
so thanks marie for for
giving us light into this topic it's
super interesting
i would like to continue
the session with an open discussion uh
actually it is uh how to be an ally so
it would be
like a kind of um rehearsal right for
for what you have already been
explaining to us so yeah i think we can
we can
unmute ourselves and
if you have any questions or you want to
comment anything regarding this topic
about how to be an ally i welcome you
all of you to to
attenuate yourselves
we can appreciate others for um some
good job they've done
yeah maybe what we can do is to when one
once we see that there's somebody doing
a great job maybe it's a good idea to
make them know that they are valuable in
in what they are doing in the in the
company
that for us it's a super interesting uh
point that they bring that they bring
out their ideas and they can speak up
about them so yeah i think it's a really
great point
if i may um add a point i i think
going back also
sort of a mixture of i i loved maurice
presentation thank you so much she went
deeply into a very important issue and
that's what relates to to asking
questions and having an open heart and
mind
and really being curious um because our
preconceived ideas
being open to have our own biases tested
right and even when we see something
that is unknown or unfamiliar to us
just watch the thought process
and rather ask questions
and and one underestimates how quickly
one can slip into it
um right and the other day's logo a
colleague ordered
tuna pizza and she put lemon juice
on her pizza and then one other
colleague
mentioned oh that's something you must
have
picked up when you were in south america
rather
here they came oh okay this i've never
seen this before
i would actually ask for a slice
you know just to be curious
all the time
thank you
yeah also i think it's very important to
know how to ask those kind of questions
and how to be polite in this in in this
when we are trying to
learn about others other people people's
culture
and
and yeah and as you said it's super
important to be open-minded um we always
have because we all have our own biases
and one thing that it's uh at least
something that triggers me or that makes
me think about it it's when i feel
uncomfortable when they said something
to me
that uh i supposed to i don't know that
i was not expecting to have or to have
that outcome so when i feel um that is
that i'm when i'm feeling that um
something it's um i don't know i'm
feeling uncomfortable with their
question or their answer it's something
that i should revise myself why it is
making me feel like that
or even also sometimes why that person
asked that or why that person had this
opinion
um this is maria i wanted to just share
something quickly about allyship
because it's really about action
and um just quickly i'll tell you
when you see something
don't think about somebody being the
need to save them
it's like how can you speak up about an
injustice that you've seen
or how can you take action
and just quickly i'll i'll just give an
example as i was in an event
with other founders and every
everyone there was um
white except me and there were a lot of
white males and i didn't have a seat at
the table so i sat outside
a white woman came in sat beside me and
said why aren't you sitting said there's
no room she said no i'm not gonna let
that happen
so she said
on the count of three this man right
here we're gonna each take our seat and
each of us sit on each other side of him
and we did she could have come in
taken a chair and gone to the table
right
but she did it and that's what being an
ally is she saw that
maybe i was uncomfortable maybe i would
be judged as a black woman as being
aggressive and she didn't come to save
me and say oh you poor thing
she just asked the question why are you
sitting and i explained and she said no
that's not fair so let's do this
together and that's what you have to
think about it's not saving someone but
seeing an injustice and taking action
and sometimes it could be something as
simple as what i mentioned
yeah i think your your um
your example it's really eye-opening of
what we can do and
and how our decisions are shaping
in the end um
the way we think and
how we can learn from from others
experiences
so for me um i would like to ask deborah
regarding um because we always uh we
always um
know the concept of dei and for me was
really eye-opening that you added
belonging to it i think it's a super
interesting point that not many people
um
say it and
um i really
um
i really value the summary that you gave
about your div
because sometimes it's very
it's easy to give a definition of all
these four concepts but um
it's not easy to have examples of it or
or examples that are out of company
right in order that everybody can
understand so um i really found i found
it uh really interesting
that um you were able to give
um really uh easy easy concepts and um
easy examples in order to understand
them
thank you so much
i think with with any social science or
any social concepts um
it it it's it's always evolving
right and i really hope that human
beings through introspection and reading
and connecting with others
we
we grow and we expand i think that's the
only way forward
you know not not to be stuck because i
even with uh
marie's cultural appropriation
i think it's a bit
it's a very uncomfortable i personally
find issue right and of course the
intent is very important
uh you know whether it's to ridicule or
not
but what if i just want to celebrate
another culture
um how and i do it literally just by
wearing a
head gear and
i actually don't believe that there is
one person who only has one culture
because
all families culture people traveled
i mean sea travel and i did a talk the
other week sea travel started before
christ international sea travel
so even before
way back you know people across
the world were connecting so i
yeah it's something i'm also
learning and discovering
and
wish we could celebrate
one another more
thank you
thanks virgo um we have another question
which is
how to have a conversation about
um tough topics or differences
and
how we can approach this kind of um
of ideas
or this kind of conversation how can we
make them less comfortable i guess less
yeah more comfortable sorry
um i mean i'll be happy to
talk about that i think
the idea is not to make it more
comfortable the idea is to
sit in that discomfort for a moment
it's really
something we're on
we're not used to it it's unfamiliar to
us but if you sit
in that discomfort for just a moment
you can start to ask what is making me
uncomfortable about this conversation
and that's i think that's what we don't
explore enough is that what is making me
uncomfortable when i hear a conversation
i have to ask myself that what is
triggering me about this
what is uncomfortable and
um how do i explain it you know in a way
that others can understand why my i'm
uncomfortable you know and
i think what's important to think about
when we're having conversations that are
difficult is
ensuring that we are listening to
understand and learn and not just
respond a lot of times when we're having
conversations around race or anything
that's difficult
we listen but our minds are thinking
what do i have this what am i going to
say in response to this as opposed to
what is not what am i hearing or not
hearing what's not being said
um and when i used to do those
compassion convos those are very
difficult because
we had to create a space where people
you didn't judge someone based on their
comments
you tried to understand where it was
coming from
because we all um we have different
backgrounds we have different
experiences we don't know what led a
person to be this way or think this way
you know sometimes
it could be anything
you know um
so we have to think about
what is making me what is making this
person and that's hard i'm not saying
any of it is easy
which is why it takes time and
we're still learning i'm still learning
we're all still learning because
we
have to understand that most of the
times we're not having this especially
in the workplace these uncomfortable
conversations these difficult
conversations and most importantly
creating those spaces of trust
can i trust what is being said is not
going to
be
taken out of this room i create that
make sure that you create agreements
in the workplace what are the agreements
that
we all agree that
is it that we're gonna respect each
other what is said
is it that we're gonna pay attention put
our phone down
make eye contact whatever it is
have agreements that everyone
um provides input
so that you can now be in a space that
you feel is trusted and you can have
these conversations and ask questions i
think
you know why do you think that is really
important why do you think that way or
why did you say that um i'd like to hear
more and when did you
or even at what age did you start
thinking this
because how we think as a child is not
how we think as an adult so what
happened
and i did see another question so i just
wanted to bring your attention to it
thanks a lot for for your answer
we have another question
which is uh
what can we do in a situation when
seniors think
that a junior woman would have less
understanding of
technicalities on the details of subject
um
anybody i can answer that unless
somebody else wants to um
that's a hard one this is like
i was reading this is the first time
where we have four or five generations
in the workplace so you have gen z
millennials gen x
boomers
and in some cases some people haven't
retired you have i think what's called
the silent generation
so
um
i would say set those boundaries
and
ensure that they're respected and what
you can do is if it's
one person have a conversation with that
person
um especially if the dynamics are
reversed where this person reports to
you
i think with somebody's senior and they
report to someone junior
ensuring that they understand
why
you're hired for a position
more than likely it's because you can do
the job so
really find out talk to them about
respect
and how much you value
their input but that if they're saying
something to you particularly if it's in
public or meetings that it undermines
what you've worked so hard to prove
and that you you know you want to have
a good working relationship with them
and you want to better understand
um
why they're questioning this sometimes
it's really taking someone aside to talk
to them one-on-one
and getting that
a lot of times people do it because
they're uncomfortable
they're someone senior is uncomfortable
with someone junior
having to report to that person or
someone junior comes in and the person's
afraid they might lose their job so you
don't know what the motive is
but i would talk speak to that person
on the side and if you feel that it's
still not being addressed then
um going a step above or finding that
trusted person you can speak to if you
have a mentor really getting them
um their their input a lot of times it's
it's around their own it's their problem
it's not yours it's around how they feel
about themselves maybe they feel
you know while
i could have this should be me why is
this person here and
you know what do they know that i don't
know and it's not about you
it's really about they need to feel
better about themselves so
they're going to the best way to make
you feel better about yourself
is to make someone else
feel
less about themselves and question their
worth so don't let them question your
worth
prove why you're there and let them know
yeah of course we obsess
as women we ruminate a lot like why did
the person say that why was this said
this way how come and this is why it's
great to have a mentor or an ally that
you can
bounce brainstorm with and talk about it
because they'll help you see
maybe you know
why do you feel this way or
this is what you need to do and they can
give you and speak to
um if you have
women in
in your workplace or in different groups
that
you can
actually network with or mentor with
find out how they've handled it
i've met so many
women founders
women who are older than i am and women
who have been through there and they
give me such great
um advice or insight find out how they
handled it and it was a different time
so maybe they handle it differently so
but the the problems don't change is how
we handle it
change you know like still going to be
the same where people have dealt with
that
but um know your worth prove your worth
and set those boundaries and ensure that
they're respected
yin jung
was saying
how would you know the workplace is not
so biased i sometimes think a place even
with
with white women they are feeling
superior about themselves and than other
races
i would just also extend this question
to imagine you are looking for a job
is there any way to know if that
workplace is
doesn't have biases or it's a good place
to go and and work for them
yes um
thank you for that question and if i
may the interview process is such an
imperative process and i think
candidates
should use this time also to interview
the company so to speak
right and and it's i believe it's a lot
for much has to do with how you do and
how you ask right there there's a way of
checking
um you know you can ask i mean how
international is the team
you know rather than ask you know how
many
black women aren't him or how many queer
people are you know how intellect or how
diverse is the team on what grounds you
know
why is this position available
you know why is this and and really use
the time
to also interview
um the company
because actually that's where one has
the biggest bargaining power because
once you signed
you signed up
as is for everything
that's in there
um on the point on
[Music]
is undermining um the work i mean i've
experienced this also extensively um
both in south africa and here and
how i fight my battles is
often it is
not not to say i can do it but to show
so if for example somebody said
something in a meeting it did not quite
fit or was not quite true it's not quite
i put it in an email and then i put the
sources
of my information
obviously it's easier you know
especially being in the legal field but
but i usually put that there
you know in terms of this or that
document this is how it is and i just
literally show you
that i know what i'm talking about and i
came here through the front door
so that's a bit of a
gangster way of doing it but just to
show that you're worth it and and
exactly all the other things you know
and allyship
and getting
to know people but but not being afraid
to stand in your own light
thank you
um she did such a great job i love that
stand in your own light i think that is
a beautiful um
phrase to embrace
and and to think about
um the only thing i would add it's just
the glass door is a really good um i
think they even added diversity so i'll
put the link
um so you can look
and
do informal interviews
if you can find if there's a company you
want to work for
find people on linkedin that work there
and just ask them you know can i connect
with you just wanna
get your um i really love this company
uh
and why you know say why you do don't
just say this is a great company but
whatever it may be
um
but
definitely ask people that work there
already
um
see if you have one or two connection
you know one connection away from that
person and ask somebody to make an
introduction for you
but
i love the idea of like asking those
questions like how many how much
diversity
how diverse is your board
this is one thing they'll know that
you're paying attention
and that you're not
you know you are on it how diverse is
your board what are your retention
numbers for diverse employees
um
what are what do you have erg groups
how are you supporting them do you have
a diversity
an inclusion person what kind of
activities
um you can even ask do you celebrate
cult these different cultural
observances these are just
employers have to start realizing these
questions are just
they're gonna
be part of the interview process and if
they want you they have to be able to
show you why you should work there it's
not just a one-way
don't feel so desperate for anything and
i know that i've been there where i've
been like i want to work for this
company so bad that i'm gonna
you know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
overthink this
but
you're worth it like
again so
definitely do the research
and how can we talk about these topics
if we are now for example in an online
environment which it makes it more
difficult to
um
i don't know how to say it but to be in
the office and see if there are some um
[Music]
some things that are going on that may
maybe we should avoid
how can you
how can you
i don't know if this and these tips can
be also um relatable to the off online
um or virtual um virtual environments
that we are working on nowadays
yeah it could be difficult because of
the hybrid you know some people are in
office some people are remote and then
people have offices
in different locations so international
us
um
it's really
if you're thinking about it from for you
as a employee
ensure that you're seen and heard which
means if you're in a meeting ask a
question
um or if somebody gives out a stat ask
more details about it
um show that you're there and you're
present
if somebody makes
if somebody says something again
documenting is key if somebody says
something in a meeting that you feel was
um
inappropriate
if you
approach it in a way that document what
was said who said it and if you can
approach um the person you report to
about it
but again
unfortunately
i hate to say this but
we usually have to do the more of the
work right we have to be the ones to
document we have to be the one to
to show and present why this is wrong
and it's exhausting
but
um
if you're in a if you're remote and
everyone's in the office
ensure that you're part of the
conversation
on slack make sure you get your slack
notifications or
reach out to people and and and let them
know what your
what you've completed if there's
something on your team and
hey i've done this part already let them
know that you're ahead of the game
um
also be a servant leader and i what i
and i i have to say this with caution
because as women we tend to over
volunteer
i don't mean to volunteer for everything
we do that too much and it
it depends on what it is
um
take a what was i gonna say take an
initiative on something that's gonna
move your career forward
don't just volunteer to look nice or to
look like hey
i'm
i'm available because then that's gonna
be what people
really
are gonna see you for and they're gonna
you're gonna be volunteered a lot of
times so
just volunteer for things that move your
career forward
um
but take the initiative on something so
that you're you're seen and you're not
forgotten
um if somebody's undermining again
you have to document what what they've
done what they've said
and um
and sometimes it means having a
conversation with that person but i
wouldn't do it alone only to protect
yourself
things can i've been in those situations
where
um
how do i put this i've heard from many
black women
and what many women of color i'm not
going to say say black women many women
of color about how white women use their
tears
as a way to um
really
feel victimized when you haven't done
anything so just be
make sure you have a witness there or
somebody else there that when you're
having a conversation especially if you
think this person can use your words
against you so um
yeah
it's hard it's difficult
but you you navigate it in the way that
that you feel
most comfortable and you'll find you'll
find your rhythm
especially if you're remote as you
continue to work and you'll find like
where can i insert myself so that i make
sure no one's forgetting that i'm here
and that i'm doing my work
yeah another question we have is
um
how do i
know if i am really
only overthinking or is the problem
really present at the company
i think this is something that is really
common when we start over thinking about
one thing and that maybe we think that
the problem is only
um about ourselves or
just me
and maybe i'm overthinking about it and
there's no issue in it and uh or if or
just the other way around if it's the
company if there's a problem
that the company has and they are
already transferring it into us
what do you think about it
that's gas lighting and it's it's it's
it's hard
but
how you feel is how you feel no one can
tell you how you feel is wrong
and um
and something my ten-year-old reminds me
too like how i feel you can't tell me
how i feel is wrong so
what you're feeling no one can tell you
that you're wrong to feel that way it's
how you feel um
what you can start to do is
notice
when is this happening how often is it
happening
and sometimes people try to cover things
up through a joke right
so oh you're too sensitive you're this
is i didn't mean it in that way
um but
more
i think more employers are recognizing
that they're going to be held
accountable
for what employees say or do
so and it could be hard i mean this is
why sometimes women take years to
come forward about anything dealing with
sexual harassment or even racism it
takes
one person to come forward and then a
few others do
so
more than likely if you feel it
it's not your imagination it's just that
we have
in a way because been conditioned to
think
maybe i'm overthinking this
overthinking
here's the thing overthinking
something
usually is simple
and if it's a little complex then
you're probably not overthinking it you
know i'll give an example if somebody
were to say
um
you're articulate
to me
i'm not overthinking that that's kind of
a slight
it means like what would make someone
say that would it mean that because i'm
you know i know why because i'm black
that oh she's articulate
but
they're gonna turn around and say but
that was a compliment to you right
so
you have
to you have to be ready and you have to
be armed with the information about why
that was
inappropriate and why
this
is seen as something that is a
microaggression
so you have to
sometimes give
the feedback
um
and help and educate
and honestly it's not our job but it
becomes our job
because
um
unless you know we have to sometimes
take ownership of things that are not
our problem unfortunately and i think
more corporations more companies need to
educate particularly middle management i
think that's where a lot of the problem
stems from educate on
microaggressions and not just do these
anti-racist these one-off trainings but
have this continuous and
um
even tied to people's
promotion
and their
reviews
how are you creating an inclusive
workforce and and sometimes it takes you
even initiating something like that
about hey
how are we addressing this
because it's happening
and sometimes somebody else may tell
yeah this has happened to me but most
often
not everybody wants to speak up for
whatever reason right we can't
judge them on that but not everybody's
going to speak up and sometimes these
conversations are being are happening in
silos um but yeah and if you have an erg
group that usually helps because then
you can
that's a space for you to be like oh my
god this is happening yeah it's
happening
so it's not your imagination it's just
it's happened so much it's kind of a
gaslighting thing like
is this happening or it's not yeah it's
more than likely happening
do you have any um
opinion about this
and that maybe you would like to share
oh this is a difficult one
in the sense that
i'm gonna agree with what marie was
saying um
i i found myself in a situation where i
was
i'm just trying to think of the context
um at the exact context but it's
something that i assumed
to be discriminatory because i've
experienced
discrimination so much
so i almost expected and assumed it and
then i had to break myself and said no
but there's nothing this person
did
or even showed
you know and i had to check my own
my own scars and my own experience that
is assume
some
some conversation or some instances as
just criminatory
and that's the first thing i was
thinking about um secondly
it's also important to you know when it
has a bit of a relationship with a
certain colleague i was not sure
everyone has read too much into it
and um that's actually something that
happened to me and i literally went to
this person and i said i'm not too sure
if i i literally said i'm not too sure
if i've read too much into but there was
a little bit of trust between the two of
us already you know we've done lunch etc
and i was just very open and we spoke
openly about it right and it turned out
that person was wrong and actually did
not read too much in and about and then
we immediately
worked through
the solution i.e
how to uh
ask this kind of question the next time
you know how to approach the issue um
the next time
and
i always then
said to her and to other colleagues just
ask if you have any
questions doubts any music whatever you
read
you know about south africa about the
continent just ask me and also just to
be open to
answer questions and not
have an air of oh they're trying to
discriminate me that's why they asking
the question but actually be open to
receive the question right and and
answer them with an open heart
so i as i said i think it's on all of us
just to do the work
thank you
thanks for giving your opinion devoe um
it's really interesting to to always
have this question and to
to have an answer even if you don't have
the answer from the person you're asking
i think it's a good tool also to find
yourself the information because
sometimes it's more
something more personal than
because it of course it's curiosity but
also it's a person it's something
personal it's about your personal
development so if the person you are
asking is not eager to ask to give you
an answer i think it's also a good idea
to to try to find other people who can
answer it or
find other kind of sources i mean books
um
on the newspapers or yeah try to try to
find the answer to your questions always
i guess
so uh in order to talk about this panel
about impostor syndrome i had several
questions and if you want we can follow
them if not we can go with the flow
so
um my first question about
imposter syndrome for you table going
for you marie
would be um
what are the or what do you think are
the signs of imposter syndrome
do they vary depending on the person or
are there like
speci specific um
yeah specific traits that you can see
in general
that's a different yeah it's not easier
i'm just thinking because it's
how do you explain it as a person
feeling it
you know how to explain it to chris i
think that's where the big challenge
lies and
even that is influenced by a lot of past
experiences right and
it speaks to different things because
obviously um
[Music]
so so i i i see that there are fellow
south africans um here and i'm so
grateful and and one thing that's
very specific
also to south africa is of course
because of apartheid you know and
black people are literally at the bottom
of the value chain and there's a bit of
a
complex and were
taught to to fear white people right
because they've always been portrayed as
as rich as wealthy as beautiful and
successful and you get into a workplace
and we underestimate undermine how much
these things play a role that we
actually do not speak out and then we
blame you know that the white man etc
but actually it's us because we don't
feel confident and we actually feel a
bit afraid you know so for me especially
when i moved to germany and that that
was a big because it was a new market a
new continent for me
right and and often i would
doubt myself and my ability just to get
used to this area here and the ways of
working um
on the other hand and speaking to a
point that marie raised earlier
companies have to do the work
right because if they create an
environment that will continuously over
weeks and months make it uncomfortable
for me to speak up because i'm not
i'm not included which means i'm not
given a chance to speak up i'm not given
a voice
then my
feeling of imposter is
a response to the work environment
right um
yeah
that's my contribution for now
um
i i love that i think
it was you know what she said just
really embodies everything you know that
i was thinking of i would say
the only thing is you know again
impostor syndrome makes you doubt
your
your skills your experience yourself
and
unfortunately makes us question
our value and how valuable we are what
what we have to offer and
it's so taxing
on the mind
when um we have to deal with impostor
syndrome and it could be simple as
someone questioning
[Music]
questioning our education questioning
our skills i think we get that a lot as
people of color the questioning of
where did we go to school and there's a
difference between being inquisitive
to learn more about someone and just
doing it because you doubt they're here
on their own merit
so it's that it's constantly having to
prove why
you're
worthy of being in a place
and one thing i'll say is if you are in
the same space as those
you earn the right to be there
yeah what i do i i sometimes when i
get a sense that certain things have
been questions or i mean i i even
get
some crazy questions and and assumptions
you know being from the continent
and
i just use it as an opportunity to
educate
um i mean i was spoke speaking about
covet and
i was asked if we have icus hospitals
with icus in south africa
you know and then i
when i watched the news that was the
time when the different um covert
variants were discovered right um and
there was a south african variant
so-called
and i was so shocked when i watched the
news
and german news they showed footage
of it it was a desert and un
refugee tents
and i was like this is not so ever now
we have very arid areas
but we don't have any desert with agent
and also
that the people who are portrayed we
have certain features in south and
southern africa and
there were more of east african facial
features
see so it was not even portrayed
correctly you know so
i i i'm grateful i didn't approach that
question with with aggression but with
understanding that no wonder this is
what you think of us and have the
question whether we have icu units in
our hospitals it's
literally what you get fed you know and
the impression created
about how we live
so um
especially when i get questions i
actually
you know i i try to be positive about it
and literally be open to give an answer
and literally
as an opportunity to educate
one thing i want to say is i always i
always say to people you're not an
imposter you're an outlier
um and
and being an outlier
really it boils down to just
being someone you know who
you're you have unconventional
approaches you have a different approach
to things
and
you stand out
for your accomplishments so look at it
that way look at yourself as not an
imposter but an outlier i maybe you've
gotten into
tech
the
you know not through college but you
worked hard and did self-study you're an
outlier you are positioned
you have done what you need to to really
make yourself stand out and you don't
follow the
the pack
so that's what i like to how i like to
approach it it's hard um but
yeah
if you can just reframe the narrative
for yourself
because
reframing it for the
for culture for society is gonna take a
long time so reframe it for yourself and
and
and ask yourself
why did i think i was an imposter i'm an
outlier
yeah
i think that tim
wanted to
contribute i don't know if you can
unmute yourself and
give us your opinion about it
thank you
um
i think uh
when you talk about uh
imposter syndrome
they
they look at it
from my perspective
[Music]
i think you ask how you can
how you can be aware that it's there
it's certainly
some sort of fear
and uh
i think the biggest
uh the the biggest
the biggest uh focus of fear is uh to
stop you from moving forward
that's the biggest force of fear i i i
have a small definition of myself that i
keep on reminding myself that
fear is not the absence of
courage
but fear
i mean sorry courage is not the absence
of fear
but it's feeling fear while moving
forward
so definitely when you see uh
when you are feeling that you're not
moving forward before you're not moving
forward
because of uh
probably that then you you should
acknowledge that
it's uh
it's something that you should probably
work work on
but uh you should be
probably move forward if it's stopping
you from for example advancing from
applying for that job
right you should be able to move
move forward while feeling fear i mean
just just look at what happened you know
fear sometimes i
i don't know i think
sometimes i feel like
we are we are too uh
as a human being we are too uh sometimes
it's good to
just take risks
i mean no one knew anything like coffee
did happen
so
thanks that's my opinion
thanks for sharing your insights
team
um
maybe we can move to the next question i
had which is um
how can we support others that are
suffering from impostor syndrome how can
we give them
tips or how can we
by our actions make them
move forward
i would say
remind them
of
the times where they have
um
[Music]
you know done something extraordinary
shattered records or it doesn't have to
be extraordinary remind them of the
times when they have
faced adversity and and been successful
remind them of
[Music]
who they are
and
and sometimes it has to be
reminding them of what they've done
because sometimes just saying no you're
great because you do this doesn't always
work so just say remember that time when
you
took on you know whatever and and
you were able to
empower others
so give them a moment in time
where they have
um maybe they've forgotten that they've
done that and remind them that
uh
everything takes time and if they're
feeling this way
why
what is it that you know tim brought up
fear
some of the the times we feel the
imposter syndrome is when we are being
we're successful
it seems that that's when we start to
question everything
when
we start thinking oh my gosh should i
really be here
even though you're doing
um
and even when we're we're not
doing it
or
we feel that we are failing
and i don't like to say fail
um
but if we do if you do feel that way one
of the things is
give that person remind them to allow a
space for grace for themselves
it's okay
you can't we're human and you're not
gonna always get it right
and so
remind them to not be so hard on
themselves but also remind them of the
times that they've done things so that
they can
keep that in mind
which is why i'll go back to
documenting things when you write down
the things that you've done
you can
go back to it and say wait a minute no i
did this
and i could prove you know so
write those down journal it whatever you
have to do keep a
just document
what you've done
especially if you're working remote
or someone else's working remote and you
want to support them
make sure that they are writing down the
stuff that they're doing how they're
contributing to the team what value
they're adding um
again dates time all that matters so
that you can go back to it and
when you're speaking about your
accomplishments and then tie it into
how you're helping the company be
successful so remind them to tie it back
to the company's success how they've
contributed to that
yeah for example in my case
i as you said i journal them
my achievements every month i just write
down one achievement that i i
i feel like it's a super thing for me
and when i feel down and i don't know um
and i feel more insecure i don't know
why
what i do is
check them again read them and say hey
you've done many things and in the last
for example now in the last 10 months so
you can see that you're already good
you have been already been been doing
lots of things that been that they've
been really been valuable for you and
for the company
and i think it's a way of moving forward
just to seeing with a kind of
perspective
how how have you been growing in the
last months in the last years i think
it's a very good exercise
and i really recommend it to everyone
yeah i'm a chip in there thank you so
much for both of it and
that is very true i actually started
doing it and it does feel good
um there's a lecturer of mine this is a
couple of years ago um who
recommended
it was an assignment it was called best
of me and the assignment was to prepare
three questions so um
so who they are how they relate to me
and
to put out a situation where they saw
the best of me
and to send that
to at least 10 people
in different parts not only colleague
for my colleagues but
also friends family
exes
whoever i had a relationship with
and i was astounded
that even things i didn't remember i did
or said
had such an impact on other people right
and then obviously by reading them all
so there's a golden thread that i
realized about my own personality and
strength and
it's also part of recording so it was uh
emailed so it's typed so it is in a very
secure folder
and because often we are we are our own
worst critics
and uh it's
we often
and and
my other classmate made attested to this
that it's
it's quite mind-blowing um
what an impact we actually have a
positive one when people runs and we
tend to undermine it because we always
consumed you know by the negative about
us so i encourage you to
to do it it's called best of me
and this should just ask question when
just put up the situation when
and which situation you
thought you experienced the best of me
you'll be
surprised and over the moon
by the response
thank you
we have another question about this
which is um
[Music]
how can we make sure that people
understand that they are enough
um
[Music]
that they don't need to overperform all
the time in comparison to the majority
of groups
i guess in this case the question is
when you are part of a minority
how to say hey it's enough i'm doing the
best i can
how can we make others know that um
we are not going to overperform in this
case
that is so
okay i'm gonna take a moment to think
that one
yeah i would say how to say enough is
enough
um
but yeah it's a really difficult
question and
because
maybe it's how you have to approach the
people like
because probably the message is clear
about
how to deliver it
is the
difficult thing
so if i understand correctly how to
encourage people feeling the impressive
syndrome or how to talk to the person
who might be responsible for your
feeling
they process syndrome
yeah how to make the other person know
that you are enough like
i'm not an imposter i'm not or maybe i'm
dealing with impostor syndrome but i'm
doing the best
i'm doing my best and this is what i'm
going to deliver to you this is all my
energy i have for you i'm not going to
give you more of what you are asking
because sometimes
i guess that when you are part of a
minority they are asking something or
you need to prove more than others
so how can we
make sure that the rest understand that
we are
like the rest of the group for example
and that we are not going to
it's overperform an easy one and we have
to be careful to always when we say
compared to the other ones are we
comparing apples with apples
you know am i actually more senior than
the one
i'm i'm comparing myself to
um so i i
i tend to
not like to
compare
myself with a colleague
in which i don't have the same list of
responsibilities and have the same
position because different things apply
right
but i
prefer to
treat each
each scenario of of injustice feeling of
injustice
or feeling of unfairness
as it is
right so i don't like to compare myself
um
to others because
especially if they're not you know we
don't have line online the same
responsibilities
um
so if i'm overwhelmed or it's
too much i mean that's i i do this to
date when i have this
long list
of things and i must do it in a few days
i actually
go to my group ceo i said okay help me
prioritize you tell me what's priority
and by when
i don't even take up because
you know and he's responsible for that
part of the business and that's also how
i avoid overwhelming myself i literally
just put it back says okay you have to
actually this is 15
tell me how what you are and then there
often they will also see that the list
is quite unreasonable
and then you know i'm fortunate they'll
say okay actually this is very important
oh and i still feel that the reduced
list is a lot
i say but you're undermining this you
know drafting this does not take half an
hour
you know actually my line of work and if
you want good quality work it will take
me two hours you know if i'm provided
uninterrupted
so
can i may i give you x and y today and
you know or tomorrow so it's about
managing the expectation with respect of
course and of course there are times you
know before audits or before year end or
before month end when things have to be
pushed through
and of course you will have longer hours
but i think
we should always remember that even when
we deal with seniors or people are
different from us we are dealing with
human beings in the end
and we just talk
and ask
um but i would definitely give it back
when i feel overwhelmed
thank you
the only thing i would add is
as i said
set those boundaries make sure that
you enforce them too
sometimes we tend to
contribute to that by
doing more thinking that i'm going to
prove myself and then you just end up
mentally and emotionally exhausted
because
you're pushing yourself too much so we
have to
also step back to say
how am i contributing to this because i
feel like i have to prove myself so
maybe i am going above and beyond and
then now that's how
whoever you report to or your team
members are going to that's what they're
going to measure you by by what your
contribution so if you've pushed
yourself
to the limit to get something done then
that's the expectation they're gonna
have and so then
if you just try to change that midway
then people are gonna now they're gonna
question you
so you have to really step back to say
what's the most i can
give
where i feel confident
that i have contributed
um in a positive way without over
extending myself because it's that over
extending yourself part
that we forget
how we do it
you know that's in anything any
relationship sometimes you go above and
beyond because you want to prove
something but then that person when you
stop doing it the person wonders well
what happened
and so then
you know it flips on you then
but all you are trying to do is show
them so you have to say to yourself
what can uh how can i prove myself
in a way
that again protects me
and i feel safe in doing it without
feeling i have to
and ask yourself what is it that you
have to prove because sometimes it is
we're getting that message but sometimes
it's also
what we tell ourselves and it could stem
also from what we were told as kids
right and the messages we get there it's
like you have to work harder like we
tell kids
you have to work harder than everyone
else to get what you and that's going to
be the message that stays in your mind
and you think i have to work hard
there's nothing there's no way around
this
but if you say that
you've earned the right to be in the
same space as everyone
do your best so when someone questions
your ability
ask them
so why
um
what makes you say that or give me an
example
sometimes when you ask people for
example that's when they get stuck and
they don't have anything to say
always ask can you tell give me an
example and if they can give you an
example and
you can continue asking questions about
um
how did you feel that i didn't
contribute
and again in the the tone is important
so that
no one can say you're being aggressive
no one can say you're being defensive
you're just you say i want to know
because i want to always make sure that
i am
doing my best
but um
also balancing
my work life
right now there's a lot of conversations
right there about that so employers know
that work-life balance
people are going to just jump ship
if you're not getting that so you have
to say i want to balance my work life so
please let me know um
and also pay attention to deadlines
because i think that's where we
overextend ourselves because everyone
has a deadline and if five people have a
deadline and they're expecting you to do
it you're gonna have to say
if you have to email everybody say hey
you've all had the same deadline
please decide which is a priority don't
let them make you decide what's the
priority because then it's gonna
somebody else is gonna be upset
but let them know open those lines of
communication and and push back a little
i think we've been conditioned to think
that we can't you can and there's a way
to do it without
feeling
you know worrying about how somebody
else is going to receive it push back a
little if you deadlines are what creates
these problems of impostor syndrome
we have
deadlines that sometimes don't even mean
anything it's just somebody creates a
deadline because they feel like i need
to have it by this time but do they
really need it so
again
if someone's giving you a deadline
or they've given you an assignment and
they haven't given you a deadline say
when do you need this buy
what are you looking for ask questions
and if they can't answer it then you say
in order for me to do this
in the way
that you would like me to do this i need
more information
have them step back i mean it's we can't
keep taking on everything so have them
give them the ownership of that
thanks a lot marie and davao for your
contributions uh they've been super
valuable and i guess all our attendants
have learned from your
from your perspectives and regarding uh
this topic be and how to overcome
imposter syndrome and how to be an ally
and also from your from your sessions uh
thanks a lot
to both of you
uh we will now go to a break a 10-minute
break
yeah so we are back in 10 minutes so at
18 10 we have another another
grateful session from ee
so i'm waiting for
uh we are so we are looking forward to
it but
yeah how we have we must have break a
minute um break uh see you in 10 minutes
i'm going to present our next speaker
now it's the time we we are back from
the break
so
now we have with us
e
uh she's an enthusiastic tech recruiter
whose people orientated she is
originally from myanmar
her family immigrated to malaysia and
studied there till her bachelor and got
her there her first job
her background is in business
administration majored in human
resources
and she started working as a common ban
analyst intern but she didn't like it so
she started as a recruitment coordinator
which really loved it and went into
recruiting in an agency for tech
recruitment after migrating to the
netherlands
while grinding after a year and few
months had an opportunity to be an
in-house recruitment business partner so
she took it and filled the taken data
teams at a company called 5c8
once the team settled another
opportunity to be embedded recruiter
approached her and she was
in for the challenge at we are keen as a
tech talent partner she works for her
client in berlin which is get your guide
and for a number and which has a number
one travel experiences booking platform
so he um this stage is yours
thank you oh idea thank you very much
for the warm welcome i'm very excited to
be here with you guys um i speak a
little bit fast so please let me know if
i need to slow down thanks for the
introduction as well i i really
appreciate it and um i would like to
talk today about dei hiring
um i would like to share my screen if
that's okay so i've prepared some slides
and i just want to share some insights
with you guys
to talk a little bit more about um
hiring in
um
in diversity basically so i've been
attacker for about a few years now and
today i would just like to talk a little
bit more about the challenges we face in
hiring dei and
also as a challenge individually as a
dei person how to thrive in an
environment that is competitive but at
the same time to be different than
others as well so i'd like to talk touch
on a little bit of both topic but first
and foremost thank you so much for the
introduction or idea once again um i'm
ee i'm very much people orientated so
please feel free to ask me any kind of
questions you have i'll be more than
happy to answer that but first and
foremost i'm a recruiter so i'm
recruiting a get your guide and i'm
recruiting and we are keen as well so
for those who are interested in
recruitment we are keen as hiring for
every level of recruiter and get your
guide is hiring for all kinds of
technical positions so i'm willing to
you know take on every kind of
introductions over here please feel free
to connect with me on linkedin as well
so get your guide is a traveling
platform and we want to pre we want to
be the travel best travel experience
provider in the world so that's our
ambition
now moving further to diversity and
inclusion in hiring it's a big challenge
and it is a big topic especially right
now that people are working in
tech and people are working with ai
solutions and automations because how
they work with ai solutions and
automation they have to
uh create patterns and algorithms and um
you know like those kind of machine
learning models and those kind of models
mimics what has happened in the past and
that's exactly how they are working on
it to hire for the future
right so if
they don't have a diverse team who is
creating those programs that those
programs are going to be biased
themselves because those people are only
looking at one perceptive they are not
expanding their horizons so that's the
case that actually happened with amazon
in the past
they created this algorithm which was um
started up in 2014 and from the past
they actually predicted how
which people would be successful and in
2015 they actually realized that the
program was predicting only white male
people to go for the positions because
that has been predicted successful in
the past so they were actually excluding
every female candidate which was act who
were actually qualified for the job or
beyond qualified at that point so that
is the critical
challenge that we're facing in hiring as
an organization even in amazon so you
can imagine all those smaller companies
will struggle as well with this kind of
algorithm so that's why diversity is now
critical more than ever
in the age of ai in you know in the age
of automation and another thing another
case in hospitals in u.s they actually
realized that the patients who were
sicker
than the normal average white
patient were not being attended to
because they were coming from a black
background for example so that was an
actual real case and if you click on the
link you can actually see that an
article that those
those cases were very real and the the
people have severe consequences of
course because they were not attended
because the hospitals were full and it's
just like the covet situation that the
people who are diverse are not being
cared for but the people who are
privileged or the general white
you know um
that that common part where it's it's a
it's a norm for example those people are
taken care of like for me for example
when i moved to the netherlands
i didn't get an opportunity right away i
was actually discriminated because i
didn't have the dutch name i didn't have
a common white name that's on another
side and i didn't speak the language so
that was also a discrimination i faced
when i was trying to get a job getting
my foot in the door and i also actually
got a lot of recruiters who were
not able to understand me while i was
telling my story and they didn't bother
to clarify and that's the main problem
with
recruiting today there's a lot of
recruiters who are out there who
actually hold the position and they are
closing the door on you so as a
diversity candidate what can you do then
that's what i'm going to talk about
today
so
um any questions so far
okay take that as a note
moving on
so how do you actually get hired as a
diverse candidate than in this case
first you have to have the basic skills
of course a lot of recruiters look at
your cv a lot of recruiters look at your
skills a lot of recruiters always look
at what experience do you have hands-on
experience is very critical so what you
really need is to
get out there and do the dirty job if
it's an open project for example if it's
an open source code learn to code if you
are into programming if you're into full
stack or if it's about a project then do
those um voluntary projects for example
where you can actually learn project
management where you can actually learn
stakeholder management so those kind of
skills will help you get your foot
through the door and once you actually
get a job then you can build it up from
it and it will get easier
and you have to always upskill and
invest in yourself i know it's it's a
little bit monotonous but you know we
are in this 2021 we always have to
upskill ourselves i what i do to myself
basically i always have an evaluation
every six months what did i learn in
this six months what do i want to
improve and then another evaluation by
another six months where do i want to go
next so you have to basically invest in
yourself what do you want to learn so
about six months ago i didn't know what
was rpo recruiting for example but now
i'm working in an agency which is an
ambitious recruited model which is the
basically rpo so i have i help my own
clients
so that's another thing you can do that
and i also went to this conference so so
in a few days ago in this week itself
and it was really a very interesting
conference where you can learn hands-on
skills about how to be a better
recruiter getting out of linkedin for
example so those kind of skills apply to
me in my career so you can apply those
skills in your career as well
and you have to define and make it clear
what you bring to the table and also
know where you stand throughout the
process now this is a little bit tricky
because there's a lot of recruiters who
will not tell you where you stand
through the process but you have to be a
little bit more proactive you have to
ask them how do you see me as a
candidate amongst others for example so
then you will get an idea where you
stand in that particular company in that
application whether you have competition
against a senior candidate or whether
you have a competition against their own
internal candidate sometimes it happens
that they're looking for a role
externally and then it gets filled by an
internal candidate so if they are in the
process they will tell you or if they
are good enough then they should tell
you if they are not telling you that
that's not a company you want to work
with that i can assure you
um not only apply to the jobs as well
but at the same time actively network
with the recruiter actively network with
the hiring team for example if you're
joining a data team find out who's the
manager of data analytics for example if
you're joining analysis team or if
you're joining a data science team for
example find out who the director is
proactively approach them on linkedin
linkedin is a very good tool that you
can actually network or for example find
them on
stack overflow or github for example you
can find those profiles
so you can do that a bit of networking
and interpersonal skills are very
important when it comes to looking for a
job so not just the hard skills that
they look at when they reject you saying
you are not a culture fit we've all
heard that we've all had that down there
down the line right and that's exactly
what they mean that
your interpersonal skills have to be
improved a little bit so maybe in the
stakeholder management you can ask the
recruiter to maybe clarify for yourself
where do you see
my improvement where can i actually
improve can you give me a little bit
feedback where do you think i lack for
this position what can i do to improve
it further if you ask those kind of
questions the recruiter can also see
that if you if you already have a clear
path for the future they will if even if
you are not a great fit at that time
they will keep in touch with you for
future positions because that's what we
do as good recruiters don't get me wrong
there's a lot of shitty recruiters out
there and i'm not saying all of them
will do that but there are good
recruiters who will look out for you
so that's what you can do you can also
keep your networking skills with the
recruiter themselves
and you need to really speak clearly if
you want to get a position and
especially if you come from a different
kind of culture i'm a very much of a
diversity advocate myself because i come
from a very high context culture that
means that we don't speak directly that
means that we talk about 20 sentences
before we get to at the actual point
that yeah you need improvement ee
we don't talk about that in the first
sentence but then i ended up in this
netherlands where feedback is a very
important thing and open communication
on the other hand is another
i need to grasp what is their way of
communication and what is the best way
for me to stand out as a candidate is
the clear communication and open
communication so throughout the process
i always ask my recruiters or whoever
the hiring managers for example do you
have any feedback for me do you have any
insights that where i can improve on
because i honestly want to improve
myself that's one and then second it's
always good to improve yourself down the
line genuinely as well
and it also gives you
third it also gives you the perspective
of what they are looking upon what they
are looking at you so if i see ee i see
full of myself but if they see me from
one perspective like okay she has too
much of energy that our company cannot
take if the company is too small for
example then i would see that okay maybe
i need to tone it down maybe i need to
um blend in better or maybe this is not
the company that where i want to work
with that's also important is that also
a match for me it's not just a match for
them
last thing is very much personal but i'm
always the
friendly recruiter and i always admire
to be one so i'm always keeping it on
the ground you know i'm always keeping
it friendly with every of my candidate
every of my hiring manager i'm keeping
it simple keeping it humble
if you keep it simple
everybody will like you because nobody
likes a complex process right we all
have our lives we all have our things
rolling so we want to make sure
everything that we're requesting them to
do and hiring managers for example if
i'm asking them for feedback i have to
simplify the process so that they will
actually be able to pick it up there it
is easy and relevant for them to pick it
up as well and find your passion i
didn't i i like hr but i honestly didn't
like common ben as um as oedia
introduced me i i hated the numbers in
in common band and i really
was tearing my hair apart so you need to
find if data is really for you or if you
want to do something else so if you if
you say you know you're really not in
the numbers if you're not able to do
those um the python language for example
or the machine learning programs you
want to explore something else you can
also do the business analyst part where
it's more like stakeholder management
documentation planning and project
management for example so there are
other fields that you can explore not
just stick to the technical part
find what you love and share it with the
others so that they also see that you
have that passion you want to share it
with your team for example so that's
what my advice is as an individual if
you are a diversity candidate going for
a position
moving further
as um diversity can be a challenge to
the organization as well as i've
mentioned earlier those cases from
amazon those cases of you know hospitals
where they
rely on algorithm and because algorithms
are not perfect because the people who
are doing it are only looking at one
perspective and not the whole of the
problem so now we're going to talk about
the challenges
as an organization faces when
you know they are trying to hire a
diversity and inclusion candidates now
i'm just going to share my two cents
with you with what i have seen for
example after they even hire a diversity
candidate what they struggle to do is
when they hire a diversity candidate
they just hire the candidate
the candidate is on board they are given
tasks about six months down the line if
the employee now of course the candidate
that the employee that diversity
employee wants to say something in the
board or in in the project for example
they are sometimes sidelined
but that is not the ideal diversity
hiring that you should do you should
always have
a member or you should always have
somebody to listen to them because they
bring different perspective and that's
exactly the point why you hire them in
the first place a lot of my female
candidates share with me that
in the tech world it's not easy for them
to survive because it's very much male
dominated
and every time they speak up
there's always one guy going no we're
gonna do that the other way not your way
because you're a minority and that
happens and when that happens that
talent will leave the company and when
that talent leaves the company what
happens you you only have the same 20
perspective on the whole problem the
other 80 you're not covering it so if
you do an app release for example that
only that 20
will look at
when you release it to the market
you're it's not going to be successful
because it's only attractive to the 20
percent and not the rest of 80 they're
just like no this app is [ __ ]
it's not including them
so it is critical for them to include
at the end of the day
you are targeting everyone am i having
any questions in the chat
yes but uh if you want a weekend you can
finish and then we can okay okay then we
do that question by the end all right
cool
um so moving on how to tackle those
quite how to tackle those challenges as
an organization you need to broaden your
hiring sources you cannot just hire
based on that amazon patent for example
you cannot just hire
only white male based on their patents
of 10 years that is a patent goal that
goes back to 10 years and they only hire
those people because the algorithm is
built that way you can't do that you
need to broaden your sources you need to
hire through referrals you need to hire
through friends you need to hire through
for example networking at conferences
for example you need to hire through
those sources not only through the
application website or not only through
sourcing
invest into a good talent acquisition a
lot of companies think that when they
hire a diversity candidate oh it's all
right we can just go to an agency we'll
just fill it what happens with an agency
when they fill it for a vacancy they
fill it okay with 20 000 euro per
vacancy for a direct level position
what happens when the candidate leaves
after six months after the retention fee
is gone
it's still another problem for the
company because the position is still
open
and the agency didn't do the job so you
need to invest in a good talent
acquisition team you need to have your
sources you need to have your recruiter
to actually
know what the candidate is looking for
if that is a match between the company
and their values
and if that candidate is also a match
for the company on their side if the
candidate will be happy with the
challenges
if the candidate would be also listened
to when they are voicing out because a
lot of times i've seen it that the
candidates are sidelined and that's a
major problem
and when i was
attending this event so soon that is
also a big issue amongst our recruiter
community because social is a sourcing
event and there are a lot of recruiters
who come there to learn like me for
example i'm an amateur recruiter i'm not
an expert but i want to learn more and
those experts who are saying it are also
noticing it that the companies are
hiring diversity but they are not acting
upon it
they are not including those diversity
employees
to be part of a major decision to be
part of an action plan to be part of
execution to be part of deployment
so it is just a diversity hire done and
dusted case we do not want to do that we
want to speak out right so this is why
we're having this
and we need to encourage team
collaboration and that's exactly
when you know you need a diversity
advocate in the team in the sea level in
the director level i don't care where
they sit whether they sit in hr where
they sit in the seaboard for example
you have to have that member
persuading
the others to listen in for the
diversity candidate and their voices
because that is the point of having a
diverse team
and that is it is proven not just one
time but many times the diverse teams
provide the most value the most
beneficial profits and they are the best
for the growth as well because they
cover different aspects
and you have to activate your employer
branding because it's not just only
about creating
the
the hiring funnel but it's also about
attracting talent you want to make sure
your brand is relevant and attractive
and it's um it stays on top of the
talent's mind so for example if i want
to choose an employer i will look for
the brand who are more open to women
hires in tech or who have more women
population intact for example so
those kind of things and you have to
also address the wage gap because
it is 2021 turning 2022 but ladies we
are facing the wage gap and it is the
fact that you know for every cent um
every dollar that a man makes we are
only making 70 of it so we need to
address it and as part of hr we need to
speak up about it we need to be vocal
and i can't do that alone of course but
i can only influence so much but at the
same time this is a universal problem
that companies need to address in order
to tackle the diversity issue there are
companies who are tackling it there are
people who are staying in the
organization for longer but
this is the time that when we need to
speak up about it so this is my
take on this topic
and i think this is the end
so i'll open the floor for any questions
i'll stop sharing as well
so we have three questions
um
i would i want to congratulate you for
for the super interesting um topic that
you've been
uh delivering
um we have five minutes well we can
extend it to five minutes so
uh and we have three questions so
i will start with the first one which is
um
how do we keep our cognitive abilities
sharp and how do we keep the mind active
and have a quick response to questions
during work discussions
that's
a good question but i mean i'm not a
psychologist so i don't really know how
to answer that but i'm going to try my
best
so what i do is
it depends on whether you are interested
in that work related topic also to keep
your mind sharp in during meetings um
but at the same time how do you keep
your cognitive abilities sharp it's
it's you can do so some exercises for
example you can do some analytical
exercises for the on the things that you
like for example like some data
collection you just do it for personal
purposes i'm not so sure about you guys
but every time i have to do a personal
purchase which is like large i will do a
whole you know like a spreadsheet
analysis to see which one will be the
best choice for example so those kind of
things that i do to keep my march out
but at the same time it's it's a bit of
a challenge for my brain to grasp right
so with a lot of things factoring in and
that's how i keep it sharp but
um that that's the advice i would give
um and it when it comes to meeting
sometimes i'm also off topic and i'm
just like um you know zoning out as well
so i'm also guilty of that um
but i try my best to be involved um
on the topic that at least i'm
interested for so like for example say
employer branding or when it comes to um
sourcing or new training for example so
those kind of topics i'm
passionate about so you have to find
what is your passion again and you have
to see if you are interested to
explore further in that in that career
uh the second question is how do we
teach
how can you teach your colleagues to
adopt a similar open and progressive
approach to recruitment
oh that is a delicious question okay um
i always
preach whenever i have the chance which
makes me kind of a nerd but um i always
say you know
there are colleagues where i have come
across um they who are you know quite
having their own subconscious i don't
want to name them but of course you know
we are humans at the end of the day so
we need to be aware of our flaws but at
the same time we need to admit that we
are humans right because we're all
humans um until the time that we cannot
automate everything we have to educate
people and i try my best to persuade
and for example say there was a
colleague who
looked at a cv
they would look at a picture and
that will form some kind of perception
in their mind
whether this person is qualified or not
but as a recruiting professional you
should not do that you should only look
at the skills you should only look at
the experience you should look at
overall not just the picture because
that is a discrimination right there
just by the picture so
how do i um address it i address it
head-on i would just you know bring them
to a room um just have a one-to-one
meeting look i find this quite um you
know something that we can improve on
it's not something that uh that is you
know very
negative but at the same time it is
something that as a professional you
should overcome if you want to be the
best or if you want to be good in your
field if you want to be fair to others
you know it's recruiting is not um
rocket science but you have to do what
is fair for everyone and that's the
thing where almost everyone gets wrong
that they have now the right and then
they're just going to reject everyone
based on their uh gut but the gut is
wrong you know even in so-so i learned
that that gut is the discrimination cut
that gut is the one that is saying oh
you're not a culture fit you know this
is this is not your company that gut you
should not listen to you should make
a competency-based question you should
make behavioral based questions and you
should only make objective um
uh what you call it observations and you
should make a conclusion from that
not from the picture not from you know
the the cv gap for example a lot of
people take it oh they had a gap but
they could be doing something they could
have had a personal issue we are only
human we need to make sure that we are
also treating others as a human you know
that's how i would teach them and that's
how um
even if they don't like me at the end of
that conversation it doesn't matter i
had to send my message across and if i
still see them doing the same thing i
would highlight it with the manager
because this is not a fair practice and
i would not have that in my team for
anyone to treat any candidate that way
so that's what i would i will first
tackle him head on
you know to whoever i have to teach if
it's a hiring manager if it's a
recruiter for example um then i will if
they improve it then that is great and
if they don't then i will talk to the
hiring manager or the the manager of the
person for example so that we can
talk about it or we can talk about
performance improvement plan
next question i hope that answers
um the last question we have is about um
the percentage of women employees in
most tech companies is much lesser than
men
how can we solve this
that's a very good question i really
keep asking myself that every day as
well
i really wish
i could solve it um
so that's this question has twofold
answer in my experience whenever i have
a female candidate i jump with joy and i
make sure that i ask her every set of
questions that i have to ask that make
that objective
analysis and i will make sure even if
there is a few red flags for example i
will make sure i address it in the
interviews so then i can discuss it with
the hiring manager up front right so
there has been some red flags
but she has this and this and this and
this and this and this
that is for you to know now com when
when it comes to hiring you are in a
very competitive field with a lot of
people and that's also another thing
that you need to consider
where you stand you know where you stand
is a very important aspect when you're
applying for a job you need to know how
big is your competition how long is the
line how senior they are for example the
all the recruiters won't give you those
answers but they will tell you if you
are in the last final round if you have
another candidate that's against you for
example so
those kind of things you need to figure
out where you stand as a female
candidate in that and if you have any
concerns or anything like for example
you cannot work 40 hours you can only
work 32 hours because you have a child
talk that with the recruiter say that
upfront so that they know it and you
have a clarity in what you can deliver
and what you cannot so
make that boundaries up front how we can
solve the
population issue to balance it out i
think we need to invest more into stem
when it comes to
training females to be more part of this
tech and data bubble for example you
know i would i would really suggest that
if people if i were to give a talk for
example say at a college then i would
really advise girls to also go into
coding i really want to go into coding
myself but i'm in this tech ecosystem
right so i'm part of it somehow but i
also want to try coding because it's not
as
it's not as bad as those
men have taught us in the past and just
like the impostor syndrome discussion
you know we were always brought up to
think that we are the one that that is
something wrong with us that we cannot
learn it especially for girls but that's
not true we can learn it as much as men
can learn it we can learn it faster
because we're more agile if you see a
man
fixating you know you you will see that
but i'm not being biased here to men or
women here but i'm just saying in
general we are more flexible we are more
agile so
we are also thinking in a different way
we have our speciality so we will find
our way into this but it's just that we
have to be encouraged because girls
being girls they are
shy a little bit they are you know not
so bold as a guy would go into tech for
example so it has to be encouraged from
earlier on
rather than tackling it now
sorry that's the question
yeah there's one more question but uh
it's on the chat so if you um if you can
answer there and because we are running
out of time and we have waiting for for
her session
so okay so we will go next with cover
last but not least the speaker
let's see if i can share it yeah
so kaver bulambo is a talent acquisition
expert and the
dndni
advocate and she's been working in the
tech industry for the last seven years
she's also the founder of my career path
and talent diverse which are both aimed
at empowering women and bi poc
professionals to build meaningful
careers and connect with each other and
employers through community communities
such as black in tech berlin and women
in work connect
so
kaveh if you want um to if you want to
share your screen and give us your
presentation
hi everybody uh so thanks for having me
um as i have been introduced my name is
cave boulambo and i will be talking to
you or will be discussing why it is
important to build a safe and inclusive
organization
in our world today
so as i have been introduced my name is
kade
i'm a founder myself i'm a talent
acquisition expert and a community
builder my background is in psychology
gender studies and public management
and once again
my love for diversity and inclusion led
me to create the communities that i've
created women and work connect and black
intake berlin
and it only made sense through the
interaction of our members but also
interaction with
my network and other employers to create
a space where everybody can kind of
access uh to
have access to opportunities and
resources and so we came up with the
idea to create talent diverse which is
basically a platform
that allows
different groups on of minority
professionals to come together in one
space and be able to access resources
that are coming through us through our
communities and so italian diverse if
you will visit the website you'll see
that we are powered by different groups
like black intake berlin or black dev uk
and women and work connect and we have
many more um small community partners
and our main goal is basically to help
them
all to let them have access to the
resources and
and support that is coming to us
yeah and if there are people here who
are looking for work we have quite a lot
of job opportunities already on there so
feel free to go on to italian diverse if
you're interested
um if you also might be wondering who
you might network with if you come onto
the platform a lot of our members are
experienced professionals uh they have
between three and seven years of working
experience
90 are working in the tech scene here in
berlin and across europe
99 percent of them of course again are
bipolar women and we have a strong
presence here in europe um almost 90
percent we have a few visitors from the
us and a few members that join us from
across africa and asia
awesome
so i wanted to do an interactive um
kickoff for this uh for this topic and i
wanted to get a little bit personal i'm
not gonna i'm not sure if i'll be able
to see
but what i wanted to
what i wanted to share
before this how do i go back
um
is they were to go back one slide i
think
[Music]
no
all right but i wanted to ask in the
room and maybe you know i'll ask later
just by show of hands
and kind of see how many of us in the
last year or two have felt
the best of ourselves when we you know
when we go to work and
how have those feelings if those
feelings have not been great
what kind of what kind of decision
do we come up with because of the
experiences that we
might have encountered in the last year
or two years uh in our working space
but since the slide has already
disappeared and i can't see everybody we
can actually do that in the end
the numbers say speak for themselves
there's a report that shows all that was
published actually this year that says
that black women are more likely to
report sexual harassment at work than
white women
on the path to entry level to executive
black workers experience low rate of
professional advancements and
compensation which basically leads to
higher rate of attrition
and the turnover rate in tech is more
than 12 is twice as high for women than
it is for men
and more than 35 percent of african
americans and hispanic as well as 45
percent of asians say that they need to
compromise their authenticity in order
to conform to their company's standard
or style of working
so this is a lot to take in and i just
want all of us to like just pause for a
little moment
again i would have loved to you know to
see people's faces and kind of see like
if there's anybody who has experienced
any of this
you know um
situations uh at work or they've hurt
somebody
or they've had reports from their own
work about such you know um
incidents
but these are some of the elements that
are making workspaces to be unsafe
and so how do we create and working
environment
where this does not happen
and just yesterday we had an event to
black and tech berlin where we had a
conversation with black women in
leadership
and it's such a coincidence that one of
the struggles that the speaker was
mentioning was the inability to bring
her whole self to work
and how black women are perceived
whenever they work in an environment
where they are the sole minority or they
are the sole leader
and so these statistics are
literally
real life experiences that most people
or most bipod and women are going
through and so if you're
a manager
listening to this conversation and
you're wondering oh it's just you know a
person is interested in how to create a
safe um an inclusive organization or
company for
you know your company then stay on
so my first idea and experience is for
you for your company to not only be
diverse
there is a quote that i found that is
very interesting and this quote is by
andre tapia and it basically says that
company have been good at creating a
workforce that looks different
but they've fallen short when it comes
to understanding how to develop a
corporate culture where all employees
feel included respected
comfortable and able to do their best
work
now
we can all agree that the conversation
around diversity and inclusion is really
like it's on top
of every company at the moment
however can we also
prove or agree
that these companies that have put the
conversation on diversity itself and
inclusion
do they have these motors where
their employees feel included respected
comfortable and able to do their best
work
and so in order for you to not only be
diverse first of all you have to
understand what is diversity
and
if you ask any company they will tell
you that they are diverse and you know
then probably you can see it
and so for me i define
diversity as all that is different and
unique in us and others that is race
ethnicity gender sexual orientation
socio-economic status
age physical abilities religious
religious beliefs political beliefs and
many many many more elements that are
not here
and my definition has been empowered by
my upbringing and socialization and i
think everybody also who's participating
here has also a definition of diversity
which is probably also defined by where
you know they grew up and what kind of
environment they've been socialized and
so if you take this to the workplace
everybody in your company has their own
definition of what diversity is your
leaders your founders your executives
they all see it in a different way but
you want to come to a place where at
least there's common ground on what is
it that we're trying to
you know to emphasize in our culture
when it comes to diversity and inclusion
and for me this is it
and so the next thing you need to do is
to recognize diversity in needs and so
once you've defined what diversity is
you need to realize that that in itself
needs to be
you basically need to realize that these
definitions of diversity that you had
will require a diverse response to each
and every category that you have
under your definition of diversity and i
think that's
that can be pretty hard and that's why
sometimes some of the strategies fail um
but i think if you you have leadership
or team that is invested in this
conversation then it can it can become a
little bit easier and so just understand
that different members of your team
organization need different structures
in order to thrive
and
when you put this into perspective
especially when you talk about the tech
industry we all know or you might know
that
there are reports out there that
the turnover rate is 50
as high for women than it is for men
why is it that women are leaving the
tech industry
at such a high rate
is it because their needs are not being
understood is it because the structures
that are in place are not enabling them
to thrive
is it because somebody is not really
paying attention to what feedback
they're giving to the company why is
this happening you can ask the same
question about bipol professionals as
well why are they
in the rates of the highest range of
attrition in companies from entry level
to executive this is really really high
you know and
pretty much disturbing if we spend a lot
of money trying to hire a diverse
candidate and then you have the high
rate of them leaving as such
a high level then we really need to sit
down and
and find out to figure out what what
what what is the root cause and so what
when we sit down and start digging deep
what is what is wrong you know what what
is wrong in our companies when it comes
to women then we find out then we put
processes in place what is wrong when it
comes to buy book professional what why
aren't they staying in our companies
then we figure out then we put processes
in place so these diverse responses to
the diverse candidates in your company
will create a space where people feel
safe people people feel included and of
course you will reap the benefit as a
company
and so the next thing
that i want for you to focus on sorry
about this youtube
my my kids basically use my computer a
lot
close that
and so you will realize that a lot of
your work actually is not supposed to be
at the top at the top level which is
basically we are diverse or we are you
know we're inclusive or we look
inclusive your work should basically
focus on inclusion and inclusion is
basically giving space
access and a voice
to the difference in everyone in your
company
and this happens basically
based on the previous point that i've
just talked about recognizing the
different responses that you need to put
in place for the different
diverse candidates or professionals that
you have in your company so you need to
give them space access and the voice and
together come up with solutions that
might work
for your organization in becoming
inclusive you also need to recognize
that inclusion is not only focusing on
how we look like as a company but it
also
looks at how we are
how
how
basically look at how we also express
ourselves uh as individuals you know and
as
as companies and as leaders is it is
very important for us to grabs
these elements
and so
the next slide will be how would
actually inclusion look like because it
is for me nice to talk about it and of
course you probably have read about it
but how does it actually look like
so
it might look like hiring good leaders
who are role models
this is really really important if you
join vernon there's an article that's
going around about
one executives who basically
has used this power to
how do i say this in the most nicest way
possible
you know to take advantage of women
professionals and you know in his
company and
and and this individual has so much
power it's such a large company they
don't like money they don't lack in
terms of innovation
but that story shook the media a little
bit in in the berlin space and this is
2021 and we still have those kind of
stories so you want to hire good leaders
who are role models
leaders who are influencers leaders
really who are interested in investing
in our people because if i'm not
invested in the people that i'm leading
or mentoring there is no way i'm going
to find out about the needs that they
have and try to put the structures in
place so that they can succeed
you also need to put in place processes
that enable employees to speak up and so
this might look like erg for example
i hope
that some of you are in companies that
have
resource groups where you can actually
get together with employees that
identify with yourself in different
areas and together to discuss about some
of the topics you know that interests
you but also some of the challenges that
you face as a group and together present
your request to the company it's so much
better when you go as a group than when
you go as an individual
the next thing you want to do
and this is based on the quote that i
read before by andrea um is to build a
culture where everyone feels respected
and valued
the reason why people feel that they you
know they need to hide who they are it's
because they believe that if they showed
who they were they will not be values uh
they will not be as valued um as they
should be and so people pulled on their
face put on a mask and put on all kind
of
personal structures you know so they can
you know they can succeed and just keep
the waters around them safe and you
don't want a company or an atmosphere
that is like that where people feel
afraid to come as they are you want
people to come you know as authentic as
possible but this can only be achieved
if people feel respected
you know and then you like i feel
respected whether i have an afro whether
i i have blue hair or whether i have
pink hair you know without transgender
you know whether i have you know a
different sexual orientation what you
know
let me come as i am if you don't have
that culture it's going to be very hard
to build a safe organization
and another thing that i think is very
important is really to continue to
educate your entire organization on why
diversity equity and inclusion is
important i don't think there is um
there is an end to this conversation or
i don't think there is a point where you
would
a company will get and say okay we're
done doing this work now you know we
we've achieved you know when we've
achieved our goal when it comes to dni
and if there was an end all companies
that are
you know that are successful on the
market could have already gotten this
right but you can see it doesn't matter
how much money a company has
in order for them to become a diverse
equitable and inclusive organization
so these are really
core
individual
values that are transmissible from one
person to another
and when our funders and our managers do
not embody
you know these qualities or this
perception about life it becomes really
hard to kind of translate that in the
entire organization
and so the benefit as you might know
already for companies that are diverse
and inclusive and equitable is
innovation
profitable and sustainability
we all heard facebook changed their name
to meta
and one of the articles i read recently
the company is really trying to get out
of this
whistleblower
incident that we all know that
basically the whistleblower
told us a lot of information about
facebook that is not really good for
humanity in general in terms of their
product and basically what they're
trying to do is to recreate another
brand that separate from the bad name
that that their brand already has you
know so even though the company already
has the largest share of the market
their sustainability model is really
unstable right now
because they actually are not taking
care either of you know their users data
they're not taking care of you know
their employee with employees when it
comes to diversity and inclusion so if
all these things might look minor
but they might hit companies very hard
at some degree
and so companies that are taking care of
becoming safe inclusive diverse
equitable um
you know will experience
greater innovation that's long-lasting
i'm not talking about innovation that's
just trending for a couple of years and
then you know it dies off
and also not talking about profits that
i gained you know misusing people's data
people information or selling products
that are coming from sources that are
not um either good for us
you know either good for the environment
so i hope
you will choose companies so you'll get
to work for companies that are
equitable inclusive
you know and diverse and i wish you know
that these
benefits you know they will become the
turn um turnaround benefits for your
company
and so what are the losses
i've said in earlier the losses of not
creating a safe working place is that
you have people living
people just leave basically they come in
and they quit as you saw in the
um in the rest of black um black
employees from entry level to executives
they're basically just living
women leaving they take space or 50 as
high as men so this is really high
because we are spending a lot of money
trying to hire people and to help them
leave
at that rate is expensive um a lot of
companies don't talk about this but it
is very expensive and when you're losing
people you're losing money of course
you're also losing profits
not only do you lose trust in customers
but you also lose actually trust in the
best employees out there like in terms
of attracting talent you might ask the
best of engineers you know in berlin you
know which companies they would love to
work for and i can assure you that it's
not going to be the top trended you know
companies that might be on top of our
heads but actually might be smaller
companies that are working on courses
that are more closer to their hearts and
that are doing good um in the world and
so you want to position yourself as a
company that is trusted you know that is
doing good that is solving a significant
you know challenge
and i mean i guess some companies are
also okay with the losses so some
companies are okay with having a
revolving door of employees coming and
going um because they've just made a
whole lot of money i'm sure we've seen i
don't know if you've seen the recent
video of amazon where they show the
workers in the fulfillment stores and
they also
show
jeff bezos going to space and him saying
thank you to all the employees for
paying for this
and so you know the the profits are
still coming in at amazon but you then
have this scenario where people in the
fulfillment are
mistreated and all kind of other um
you know
experiences are going on there
so you want to make sure that you're not
that kind of an employer um that you're
building a safe space for people to
thrive in as an organization
but also i think from an employee's
perspective these are the things that
you can actually use to define if this
is a place that you want to work at
you want to decide based on this you
know
findings if you will thrive at this
organization if you're able to build a
sustainable career um
i don't think it should only be about
the power that company
companies have you also have power as as
a candidate and you have the autonomy to
decide where you're going to contribute
a lot of your time
in terms of work so that the company can
benefit from you you also benefit so use
them as well do the research before you
join any company and see if you'll be
able to thrive as a woman or a bipart
professional
yeah and in closing i would love to
leave with this court and this court
focuses on women and i'm focusing on
women because
the world population
half of the world population is women
and
it is very important that we take care
of the circumstances and the structures
in our society in our world
to understand
why is it that women are not thriving in
our society
and like chimamanda says culture does
not make people people make culture
if it is true that the full humanity of
women is not our culture then we can and
must make it our culture
we have to make sure that our workspaces
are inclusive and safe for women and by
pog because they are half of the world
population they could be half of your
employee
numbers
you know and so if you don't take care
of that if you don't want to look at the
world in that angle then um
you
are not interested in diversity and
inclusion and you shouldn't present
yourself as if you do
because there's just a great number of
people whose needs and concerns you're
not you know paying attention to which
you
should if you want to build um a safe
and inclusive organization
and so that will be the end and i'll
open the flow to questions
thanks a lot and cave for your for your
amazing presentation
we have for example one question is um
yeah and how do you recommend
and should companies approach addressing
the needs of the different diverse
groups without appearing to prioritize
one diverse group over another
okay so to be honest with you um
companies have been prioritizing gender
diversity
and
also to be honest with you when it comes
to danger gender diversity it is white
women first and everybody else comes
after
um
and so this just depends on the
awareness that the team that the company
has put together
the understanding of the
intersectionality of diversity
and so if i
am your diversity and inclusion officer
i should already come to the table with
an understanding that when i talk about
women i talk about all groups of
groups of women i talk about white women
black women asian women transgender i
talk about basically
i take a wheel of intersectionality and
i'll put it there as my source of
practice
in every strategy that i'm going to
bring about
but then again you have it in such a way
that when companies choose who their
diversity and inclusion officer are
going to be
it's
most of the time people that are not
going to challenge them because it's
just easier to work with people that are
not going to challenge you um and so
that officer is responsible for making
sure that there is no over emphasizing
of a certain group over the other
however i will also say we saw last year
that the black lives matter movement
put black voices
at the center of the conversation and so
most companies now started focusing on
the experiences of black professionals
at work
and that all went
you know great and then we had you know
the asian hate situation
and then companies now like oh my god
you know we didn't know asians also
experienced you know racism and so they
started now jumping to the next uh
grouping
and in the end as a company you don't
want to be jumping from this group to
the other to the other to the other only
when something bad happens you really
already need to come to understanding
that there are structures in the world
that put people based on their gender
risk class or whatever their diversity
you know background is put them at a
disadvantage and you put processes in
place that are not responsive only to
what's happening outside but actually
continues with your business plan as an
organization
yes as you stay
as you say there are
many companies that are trying to tackle
one problem at the time and when in the
end they have to tackle all of them at
the same time so at least the effort is
bigger the first one as a first step
absolutely thank you for all the
good messaging you can see in the chat
coming
thank you
let's move now to the panel then
and let's see if we have more questions
after
thank you so the panel we are going to
have now
it's um
with ee and cabe about the future of
work
so i have prepared several questions for
this
um you can stick with them if not
you can
continue as
as uh as best as you know
so the first one would be uh
who we should involve in order to have
a better environment in the company
should we uh approach our colleagues
should we approach the board should we
approach i don't know another kind of
level
you know it really depends on the
company if it is a very small company
then yeah executives for sure but if
it's a bigger company like facebook for
example the executives aren't doing
anything it's not in their mission teams
that's happening the company culture is
more localized so they have the smaller
mission teams where they focus on each
specific task and those culture is the
one that the managers should look out
for and that's that's where it should be
changed if anything has to be changed
yeah another angle to look at it is as a
founder you are the culture
you are the visionary behind the product
that's coming out of the market and a
lot of people join because of you you
know because of the innovation that you
bring to the world
and so if you're
if you're a person that is not conscious
um
you really
are not a conscious leader and you make
decisions that actually are not
reflecting the world that you live in um
then there is a problem basically
everybody is going to replicate the
motto or the values that you're bringing
out as the founder
and then the founder influenced the
executive team and the executive team
influences the you know the hiring
managers and so on and so forth so
it's good to start at the top
but then again you can have a bottom
down approach where employees can
unionize and kind of form um
groups of power but then it just becomes
a battle you know between the company
and the founder i mean the employees and
and the executive teams you know trying
to tell them you need to create a
self-working environment and they're
like yeah you need to keep working
you know so
honestly i believe it comes with the
founder
and
for example yourselves how do you
envision the future of work
how do you think that
the situation or
jobs are going in the future in the near
future i would say
awesome so i uh i read a couple of
articles before covet and around the
future of work and the article said that
a lot of the jobs of the future are not
there yet
um and so there are a lot of um a lot of
skills that are going to be needed that
we all do not possess right now
and so what i can recommend is to be in
a continuous learning kind of mindset
where you're always updating your skills
because the skills of tomorrow are not
nobody has the skills yet to build what
will come however there are trends that
the future of work is data-driven it's
technology
it's innovation you know and so if you
are in an industry that is slow pace and
you know that's still very manual you
know
yeah like just
stop moving yourself to where there is
creativity there is innovation there is
improvement you know in order for you to
stay um
thriving
but also the future of work right now i
see it's very centered on the employees
um it's giving employees the power to
determine where they would love to spend
their time now we have the power i don't
know if you've seen around the
resignation
um how do you call that the season of
resurrection resignation resignation
yeah it's going on yeah
yeah it's still going on it's
it's it's still happening and um well
i've also read some articles that you
know it will settle down at some point
but
the power will remain with the
employees or with the talent basically
it is because it's because there's a lot
of opportunities around there's a lot of
people who are hiring but at the same
time hiring is still a problem there are
people who can't find a job and they
need to the employers need to um
face it basically because let's face it
um in in the talent acquisition people
know that you know it during covet there
was hiring freeze what did the companies
do they they put on hold for raises they
let people go and that's exactly why
they're having this shortage right so
now this is their time to battle up this
is their time to level up against what
is going to come ahead
it's not absolutely
it's it's i've also read a post where
there was a startup a scale-up actually
um hiring for you know people and it was
a candidate who was asking for shares
and it was not the company's culture to
provide shares but then for that
candidate they actually made it happen
because they needed that skills they
needed that expertise so things are
going to happen if you bring
the right values to the table you know
you know you need to know what you bring
to the table and you need to define it
and you need to know that
you need to own it basically
but yeah it will also be
it will also be you know upscaling is
very much irrelevant to our kind of days
now because as calvin said you know we
don't know the skills that's going to be
needed in the future we don't know the
jobs that's going to exist in the future
people in ta don't have any clue about
it as well so what can we do to prepare
ourselves we just have to
get into the mindset of continuous
learning and we have to be relevant to
the job market whether you want to go
contractor or whether you want to you
know do self-employment whether you want
to do a
entrepreneurship that's up to you of
course but in general they are always
going to be people who are looking for
jobs and they are always going to be
people who are looking for a stable
paycheck so that's
more towards that you know the future of
work but it will settle down after this
coveted boom but now it's still the time
of great resignation so people are
residing left right and center
absolutely yeah i was going to add the
future of work is also going to be
remote
and flexible we've seen that you cannot
work from anywhere there is no turning
back to that a lot of companies have
made their offices redundant
um
yeah you you can do work from it you're
saying again much power to us it's
flexible if you have kids you know you
can work you have your kids at home your
kids can appear in your video calls no
problem we all understand
and so i think the future looks good for
candidates that will stay at the top of
what's happening and update their skills
um and
yeah and countries that are good at
sporting opportunities
yeah uh we also have a question in the
chat saying uh what if there if you see
any trends in terms of self-employment
yes especially in the recruitment space
a lot of senior engineers are preferring
to become consultant or basically a lot
of work that can be done on the computer
you know that doesn't need a lot of you
know
physical interaction
a lot of those people are preferring to
become consultants and freelancers um
and i think
if you're
of that mindset i will definitely
encourage it because companies are also
making changes in the way they contract
even their employees you can join as a
freelance full-time employee
i mean that did not exist that before
covent and because of the shortage of
skills and experts on the market
especially in tech
there's a need to change the way we're
contracting people and
freelancing self-employment is really
the rights and companies don't mind
anymore because there's just a huge
demand
hundred percent agreed
okay and i'm going to ask you a
difficult question um
or i think at least i think it's a
recruitment bring it on
okay yeah now it's my time to ask not
you
so
is there something from the past that
you would bring to the future like
um
culturally speaking
from the workspace
adaptability
it's really important
as a person as an individual you need to
know where you're going and you need to
know
what you need and what you need to
unlearn and what you need to learn more
so you need to be flexible about
yourself about your skills about where
you stand once again you know i keep
going back to that same point but you
need to know where you stand as part of
the team you need to know wait what you
bring to the table as part of the team
is very important and if people are not
flexible for example because i come from
a very
conservative culture right if myanmar if
you know they are going through a civil
war right now so it's a bunch of
stubborn people not trying to listen to
anybody just trying to shoot everybody
so that's basically what myanmar is so
from me from where i grew up
adaptability is very important for you
to survive not even to make a living but
for you to survive in order to know how
to get out of it in order to know how to
make a living out of it or how to get
you know how to get out and then make a
living of it
basically so it's a very important skill
and i think as an individual i want to
bring it
into the future as long as i can see it
because if you're not adaptable if
you're not flexible you're not going to
fit in anywhere
i would love to bring in people
interaction
um so the world is becoming
more digital
and um
through the ages of covet we've seen
that um
this the interaction that we had with
people before copied was really
important um in terms of our mental
well-being
and i will still continue to
do that in the future where we have the
opportunity to work together i'll be
together in some form of ways especially
as communities i wouldn't
um i know it take it's digital it's you
know we should do the fastest and
quickest thing but i will still keep the
human element in the future really
uh no not many robots
a lot more people bring a lot of people
interaction in the future
so we are talking about the future as a
place or an environment of change
do you think that this change um
we can
ourselves as individuals can also
contribute to this change or are only
the companies the one who have the power
for it
i mean where we are the future we are
the companies
that we are building the companies we're
basically creating the future every day
i think there is a coach that says um
don't think about tomorrow
but think about today as tomorrow
um and when we talk about the future
where based every single
step that we take today
is basically determining the kind of
tomorrow we're creating and that
tomorrow cannot happen without us
if there is a tomorrow that's happening
without us then we're basically stuck in
the in the past basically like we're not
growing we're not evolving we're staying
we're static you know
but i truly believe that we are the
powerful
beings creating
our tomorrow as individuals that we have
that capacity and autonomy and then we
bring that to the different
organizations that we go with and spend
eight hours a day
with them so that we can create their
product future
so we can decide
which future do we want to create with
which company
100 agree we are the future it's no
longer
the companies creating the
the the culture or the standards
basically we are we are the future we
set the tone we said we
as people hold the power because as as
with the great resignation companies
need employees to function they cannot
function without people robots are not
functional ai you can forget about it
especially in hiring you know it's
people are talking about it but it's not
happening yet especially because of
those diversity and automation issues
because they cannot oversee that fact
you know so
until they can automate things until
they can bring robots in and have them
have empathy for example or human human
um skills basically like interpersonal
skills you know the communication skill
as a human until then they cannot
replace us so we as the humans we hold
the power moving forward and especially
as kava said the flexibility is the
future the remote part is the future and
we set the terms we want to work
remotely we want to have flexible hours
we also want to have human interaction
and they have to set it right they have
to do it right now so that's that's
that's the future
and what is the role of feedback in the
future
giving and restraining people
very very important it's not
it's not just in the future it's also
important now i think if you have open
communication feedback is very very
important and also important is that you
don't take feedback personally you take
feedback in order to improve every
sometimes people tend to take feedback
like okay you know that's a little too
much that's a little too much into my
personal zone but don't take it that way
take your time to digest it take your
time to uh
process it healthily and then
reciprocate it in your work life because
it will improve your professional career
it will improve and it will take you to
the next opportunity the next step and
this is how you grow in a professional
career at least in my opinion cover
absolutely
yeah absolutely if you
think about feedback as data
a lot of the times when you talk about
diversity and english and they ask you
waste the data well can you prove that
you know 50 of women actually leaving
you know the workforce
and you can actually use feedback as a
form of data collection and use that
feedback to make informed decisions like
every business decision that i know that
determines the okay errors for the quota
is basically because of the feedback on
the product this feature did not work
this ux is bad you know we need to
improve it in in this way why can't we
do the same when it comes to people and
culture within the organization
you know so if you think about it as
data that is important
and
useful for your growth and innovation in
your company you're gonna take it with
you every day of your life basically
[Music]
you have a question from davide rizzo
who says who asks uh will tech work will
take work become more about people
people humans communication and empathy
can we imagine that becoming a trend
so the trend right now is moving towards
what we're not focusing on people
you know we're focusing on machines you
know that's that's where you know most
of the innovation is going
but i think we can continue to
influence and advocate that the
technology that we're building
is authentic and has a lot of empathy
and bringing people you know putting
people at the center of what's being
built um but right now i don't think
it's a trend i think right now the trend
is
you know do the fastest thing as
possible
do have as less interaction as possible
with humans you know um so that you can
get what you need to get done
um and um we're basically cutting people
off at the moment from my from my view i
don't know about you
so from my perspective i think it's more
about enabling people so people will
never be out of the picture in my
opinion and i've actually had this
conversation a few times with the cto of
the previous organization so
i believe and he also believes in
enabling people with technology so that
means that we replace robots to do the
things that are mundane so in the sense
that if i have to send an email 20 times
a day i will make a robot test that and
i will not do that and i will get to do
the fancier things in in recruitment say
i will get to do the interviewing for
example instead of doing administration
so
instead of having a coordinator
i will replace that task with the robot
and then the coordinator can become a
recruiter in that sense so that is what
i believe in that is going to be the way
for the future it will not become people
orientated but it will be it will take
away the mundane task of what people do
at normal times and that will become a
trend because that will support the
human to do a better job at
you know being an overall rounded job
for example which something the robot
cannot do
if say they can replace the robot
interviewing that's still an if and
instead of a when at this point because
they don't have empathy they don't have
they only can
predict patterns they cannot understand
the tone they cannot understand the
different variations in the voice for
example or facial expression they are
still having problems with facial
recognition with different colors of
braces on iphone for example it's
because of the differences in the facial
recognition it's not just a white face
but it's a different color phase so
at this point how are they going to
mimic or understand what kind of facial
expression means what you know we humans
have a lot of expressions so i don't
think the tech will be able to replace
us or
it will not become about what people can
do but it will be about what the robots
can take and we're going to give that
task to the robot
at least that's my perspective
any other questions
um yeah i have a question
so
we
what would be the signs that we are
going in the right direction
and the world
as um in the future of work
in the tech industry
i mean a lot of things
are showing us around the world that
were making we have not been making the
right decisions
i mean if you just look at the
environment we have not been making the
right decisions and we need to make you
know to start making the right decisions
when it comes to the environment you
know we are leaving the repercussions
when it comes to technology we also need
to understand that the way technology
has been built so far
has been exclusive
and has been some of it has been
mischievous and we need to change that
we need to build technologies that are
empowering that are reflecting the world
that we are living in but are also
solving challenges that important
challenges over our world not putting
for example kids at risk or women at
risk but we're actually building tools
that will take us to the right place as
a as the world and as people not tools
that will destroy us
of course i think this is the
you know the
the positive person in me or the how do
you say
optimist in me
that loves to see the positive but i
also know that in the world it's all
about competition and power
and the more competing you are the more
influence you have in making decisions
in our world and so this competition
will continue
and form you know different kind of
world powers that will determines who
makes decisions
and so
all these
societies and groups of people who have
felt that they don't have the power to
make important decisions that influence
our world i think the their unionization
in
realizing that they could also have a
power as a unity
you know
collide for example intake and start
building solutions that are inclusive
and that are also solving you know uh
important problems and kind of kill off
the big
monopolies up there
hopefully
that's the optimist in us
would you like to
eat to
give more insights regarding this
question
no i think i completely agree with kava
because you know the competition is
there at large but at the same time we
have to look at the
how far we have come through with
technology right we it's not like over a
day we've developed this we have we've
had our evaluation evolution over time
you know it's it's
it's
one step at a time i would say because
everything it's about
taking a step at a time and then
reflecting whether it was right or not
so we cannot
we cannot predict as a um i mean i'm
just a recruiter
what do i know right like a lot of
repetition that i have online you know
everybody hates recruiters so i i cannot
just comment on where whether we're
going right or whether we're going wrong
you know it's all very much subjective
and as to my perception as well so
as the competition is out there you know
you you need to be aware of what you're
doing and i think reflection is very
important to everyone who has
that power to make a decision whether if
it's for yourself or for your company is
the larger the responsibility is the
larger you have to reflect the more time
you need to reflect because there's a
lot of people who are following your
direction whether it is right or whether
it is just to fly to the moon for fun
you know it's
you have to decide
yeah
yeah it's true
so i would like to thank you and both of
you for giving us
um super good insights about the future
of work
um
this workshop is coming to an end but
before that i would like to give like
some conclusions or some things that
i've been writing during
this whole session doing this
whole workshop about each of you as um
as um how you call it as speakers
so for example um
from from toboggan for example we've
learned how the state to school is um
still in us
and how we have to tackle it
and how it is important to add a
belonging to the dei process
and how we should interact with it and
how we should
try to blend it into into our realities
not only the eye but the ib adding this
b to the to the table
uh from marie i would say that we've
learned how to understand
or that we should understand um
our worth
in order to give the best of ourselves
and to understand or to yeah to
understand also
the value that we are bringing into our
companies
and how to then in
that we should be able to identify at
one point
um the people that we can trust in our
in our companies but also i would say in
our communities in order to
express our emotions if we are not able
to express it in in our companies in our
teams at least at least to
find it in someone
from the whole company
and trust and give them their trust
our trust sorry
from me we've
learned
how to find that is very important to
find our passion because it's passion
what is keeping keeping us moving
and
also some tips that we as hr
workers or employees we should apply in
order to
be as passionate as he
in her job
and
from cafe we've learned
why women in baipoc
leave the companies
how why
how we should address or how should
companies address this problem because
it's something that it's really
happening at the moment and it's
something that it's really urgent to
work
and also we have learned from her
that uh we should we should educate our
organizations
about why the eye is important
and i would also add this be as bogo was
adding
how
we should educate our organizations and
teams why belonging is also important
so thank you all for your time today
tonight or this morning
it depends on on where you're located um
it's been really insightful your uh this
um this series
and i've learned a lot i hope you've
learned a lot also
and um yeah so
also to finish uh i would say that
please feel free to contact us if you
have more questions or any doubt
i guess all of the speakers will be glad
to answer and i would also be glad to
answer or i don't know give you feedback
or anything you need and just to remind
you that at eight o'clock well in sorry
in 15 minutes 14 minutes to be exact um
we have our last uh key speaker
which is now me setter
and i invite you to to go and follow her
because uh i'm pretty sure her talk will
be super inspiring
so have a nice day have a nice weekend
all of you and hope to see you super
soon